dr robert malone it's robert right i got
his name right yep all right cool he was
on a joe rogan podcast it was it was a
fascinating fascinating episode and i
will i will start this show off by
saying something very simple if you
support
shutting down the voice of scientists
you don't believe in science that is the
opposite of science dissenting voices
must be heard so they do this podcast uh
it was uploaded to youtube i don't think
it wasn't uploaded by joe as far as i
know but it did get deleted
in that episode malone talks about how
he's been banned from twitter and for
what reason i guess coveted
misinformation he mentions getter well
only a few days after this show joe
rogan posts that he is signing up for
getter which i don't i don't think he's
the first person to make this jump i
mean a lot of people were already on
getter it's basically a twitter rival
but many people immediately started
setting up getter accounts because
you've got to have somewhere to go and
the challenge is for
whatever the faction is that's not the
left moderates independence post-liberal
conservative we need a word for because
the right isn't necessarily correct
there's certainly left-wing individuals
who agree with free speech and things
like that who are more on the side like
joe rogan's not a right-wing guy you
know what i mean
but these people trying to find a place
where they can congregate in the event
they do get banned from twitter so now
we're seeing a major boom in getter 150
000 new users in one day
i think they fear joe rogan especially
with podcasts like this i got to be
honest i i struggled to find the episode
no joke we'll get into all this stuff
but i think this is this is a really big
deal we've also got some data on joe
rogan's ratings as it relates to all of
the big mainstream cable channels and
suffice it to say his ratings are like
three to ten times or even more uh
larger than mainstream tv shows we'll
talk about that we'll talk about uh rand
paul he's he's dropping youtube he says
i'm not gonna be on this platform
crazy story out of australia
a man immolated himself in protest of
the coveted mandates and then we got a
surge in democrat retirements just
getting worse another another democrat
announced they would not be seeking
re-election i think this is like two for
the past several days or whatever so
it's going to be it's going to be a
crazy year my friends let me just say
it's 2022.
last year was was an off year okay there
there were some elections sure 2022 is
the midterms it's going to be all out
balls to the wall censorship smears
harassment everything you name it anyone
who challenges the establishment is
going to be
is going to be targeted with all of this
stuff it's everybody i don't care if
it's left or right whatever now for the
most part i think the establishment be
it established republicans but mostly
the democrats they're gonna be playing
dirty
you know that they have allies in big
tech we saw what they did with the
hunter biden laptop they're gonna be
coming for everyone on this show they're
gonna be coming for for you guys you're
gonna get banned for nonsensical things
like saying learn to code so pay
attention to what's going on and that's
why the story about getter is so
important
joining us to talk about this and and
much much more is that jalani how's it
going man you want to introduce yourself
yeah uh it's my second time on on tim's
show and i'm happy to be here again um
i've been a journalist for about a dozen
years i worked i think progress the
intercept
a few other different outlets and today
i freelance and also i have a sub stack
at inquiremoor.com i write about
politics and current affairs
follow the same issues that tim does
and generally uh try to stay on the beat
of under-reported stories and sort of
near
picking apart narratives i think that
are out there that you know aren't
actually supported and kind of getting
again getting that news out there that i
think that um you know you're not gonna
you're not necessarily gonna see it on
the cnns of the world so cool right now
man thanks for hanging out with us we
got luke there's a lot of crazy
narratives out there so i'm really
interested in this conversation set
thanks so much for coming and i would
just like to say today i'm wearing a
shirt in honor of the 700 sheep near
hamburg germany that just took part in a
propaganda effort the
shirt reads
y'all went from sheep to lab rats this
is definitely not a shirt for the timid
it's a great conversation starter and
you could get yours on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com and because
you do i'm here thanks for having me
this should be a great conversation i
always love sitting down with zed
because he always has really interesting
things to say and he has like such a
wide range of knowledge so i'm stoked
for this evening i always love monday
nights you guys think i'm crazy but i do
like work so let's get going ian is not
here
his flight on the way back uh went
through a rift in the time space
continuum however ian at the time was
asleep and only the people who were
awake vanished as they passed through
this rift we got word that he and a
small group of people fought off
gigantic walnut-looking monsters that
devour time and were able to get back in
the plane and take off go back to sleep
by lowering the air pressure and they've
woken now they're going to be landing so
ian should be back by around 9 00 p.m
special bonus points to anyone who knows
what that was a reference to when you
super chat us that because uh i haven't
seen that i'll leave it there you guys i
i do but but thank you doc thank you
there don lemon appreciate that yeah
yeah that wasn't a reference to don i
know it's a reference to something else
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but don lemon
made another prediction on national
television it's good stuff too that was
uh
was not sucked into a black it was not
no all right before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member and
help support all of our journalism we've
got this report here rally against you
hatred in brooklyn elad on the ground we
have on the ground reporters and it's
thanks to you guys as members that we
can do more of this and we want to keep
doing more we want to hire more people
we've already recently hired another
journalist we're looking at ramping up
our fact-checking organization this year
all thanks to you for supporting us as a
member you'll get access to exclusive
members only segments of the tim cast
irl podcast those go up at 11 pm monday
through thursday as well as a ton of
other bonus content like tales from the
inverted world this is these are mystery
stories and investigative stories in
fact one of the latest stories
is about a serial killer who is
currently active in long island so it's
not politics mainstream newsbeat but
this is pretty serious stuff it's not
always but stuff you definitely might
you'll probably want to hear about if
you're concerned about i don't know
serial killers but there's also other
stories ghost stories mysteries and
don't forget to like this video right
now subscribe to this channel share the
url to this video wherever you can that
is the most effective way you can help
us combat or compete against the
mainstream media and their narratives
and their lies we don't have those big
marketing budgets we don't have big
billboards everywhere we can't afford to
work deals to get this show put in
airports but if you guys really do like
this show and believe in it sharing it
wherever you can they can try and
silence that but for the most part it
usually breaks through and we appreciate
the support let's get into that first
big story joe rogan leads move to get
her after twitter bans dr robert malone
rep marjorie taylor green rogan's move
comes after twitter banned rep marjory
taylor green and dr malone for covet
misinformation but i don't think joe
rogan jumped uh signed up for getter
because of marjorie taylor green i think
he did it mostly because dr malone told
him on his show he was banned and then
he signed up for getter now i want to
make one very important point before we
get into all of this stuff joe rogan
is the biggest podcast in the world even
still after leaving youtube and itunes
still the biggest podcast i gotta say
i see his numbers put out by uh um you
know spotify compared to nielsen ratings
spotify is saying this is a luke
rutkowski on on twitter i heard about
this guy before he's pretty good he's
pretty good joe rogan experience 11
million viewers per show
wow holy cow 11 million
that is substantially larger than uh
what we get on this show across the
board true and uh we could only hope to
ever reach that level of viewership but
that's joe rogan of course it is when he
says hey guys i'm kind of worried about
the censorship i'm going to get up on
getter there's going to be a lot of
regular people who aren't deeply
entrenched in politics we're going to do
the same and this is huge in the battle
against censorship it could be good
could be bad now it is good but there
could be some bad to it i'll say this
a lot of people
who are being censored who have been
banned have found a voice on other
platforms like parlor gab getter etc but
the the big tech you know collusion
comes after all these platforms we saw
what happened to parlor we saw what
happened to gab gab starts building its
own infrastructure
getter may experience something similar
but at the very least for the time being
if you get banned from twitter that's
somewhere you can go and see many people
talking about you know certain ideas
it's not perfect
but i i think coming into this year
the big risk is that if we have two
separate echo chambers and people can no
longer communicate at all
well then i think the divine in this
country is going to get way way worse
absolutely we're having
one of the key instrumental figures that
created the mrna vaccine we're having
congress men and women being banned from
expressing their dissent
towards the the narrative and they're
getting axed they're getting their
ability to talk to their constituents
removed away from them by what power
what god-like authority big tech social
media that literally just deemed it to
be not appropriate for the general
public to hear i'm sorry i mean once you
start censoring information once you
stop eliminating the people to even have
a debate or an honest conversation
you're on the wrong side of history and
what joe rogan has done is he has
put people who have been censored in a
way where their voice could actually be
heard they could actually release their
ideas to the general public and this is
a huge step against the big tech social
media monopolies and this is why i
joined getter because
and again i don't even know much about
getter i still need to do my research i
still want some kind of reassurances
that get or won't become the next
twitter but but but still this is a
swell of movement of people saying hey
this is crazy i i i can't deal with this
i want free speech is that did you sign
up for getter uh i have not signed up
for ghetto yet i am on rumble which is a
youtube competitor yeah um yeah we use
real moments so
uh you know i think something important
to acknowledge here i think a lot of
people you know they look at these
decisions by these companies and they
say well they're private companies
they're they're behaving and
that they get to control who who their
users and their customers are this is
any store any any business organization
would something people have to
understand is that over the past few
years
the government has increasingly leaned
on these companies you know democrats
will bring these people before hearings
they'll bring up inflammatory content
and they'll talk about this and they'll
basically ask the companies why they
aren't censoring more now the government
of course has various regulatory powers
it could impose on these companies that
could
you know cost some profit they could
reduce their market share that could
even break them up and i think that a
lot of what these companies have been
doing over the past few years uh for
instance what they did with the hunter
biden stories where facebook and twitter
were throttling the story making it
difficult to even click the link uh to
go and read the new york post story
about
president biden's son
i think a lot of what they're doing
they're doing that preemptively to avoid
potential regulation from the democrats
so it's not so simple as private
companies simply making enlightened
decisions you know playing hall monitor
on speech they're actually doing this
with political aims uh in mind in that
they know that this party's in power in
washington right now so they have to
keep them happy and i think there's a
lot of democrats i think there were some
democrats who were interviewed about it
like prominently paul who were very much
in favor of marjorie taylor green being
removed from twitter they probably
wanted them to go further than that so i
think you know you have to understand
this is this whole thing's an ecosystem
it's not just a company acting in a
vacuum i mean i think facebook did a 24
hour suspension of marjorie taylor green
almost immediately after twitter removed
her right in concert
i would i would actually disagree with
you i don't think big tech is afraid of
politicians i would say politicians are
afraid of big tech especially with the
amount of money that they put into the
lobbying business i think they're the
biggest uh one of the biggest uh
lobbying efforts in all of washington dc
and they control a lot of
power because they get to see everything
that politicians do now you don't need
the cia anymore you got facebook
literally knowing when you're going to
take a dump so if they know that they're
tracking and databasing all these
politicians and probably have a list of
dirty laundry against them and they
could go to them be like hey we know
what you googled we know what you looked
into we know the private videos you
watch on this and this website we could
release that to the general public
unless you do what you want us to do so
i think big tech especially with how
they were working with the intelligence
agencies from their beginning are the
ones really in charge here from my
perspective but again i might be wrong
think about how insane it is to take
down
an actively sitting politician
right twitter banning marjorie taylor
green i mean first of all banning trump
that was crazy
people don't realize this man you get
you get the cnns you get all these
networks being like an insurrection
occurred so we must remove the current
president from all of these social media
platforms so you can't communicate he's
not going away his followers aren't
going away this is not shutting anything
down it's only proving to the people who
don't like you you're as bad as they
said you were if you've got people if
they're if they're telling us that
there's an insurrection you've got
people who genuinely think the democrats
and the neocons are like evil and need
to be removed or whatever and then you
decide that the one person they do like
trump is going to be removed from public
discourse that just makes it worse it
makes it substantially worse i think
back to i think it was george washington
there was this um
i'm i'm blanking on the guy's name but
there was a a conspiracy
do you guys remember this like the
revolut after the revolution america
couldn't pay its debts and a bunch of
soldiers weren't paid so there was like
some insurrection and george washington
was like no no no we gotta let these
guys go if we if we prosecute or
persecute them it'll only make things
worse oh yeah i can't remember i can't
remember the full details and you know
we talked about on the show once but
that's what a lot of people talked about
back during the insurrection people are
much smarter than i mind you they said
perhaps amnesty for these people is the
best way to do this to say look we're
we are we are one country we need to
come together we don't want to make
these problems worse instead
the establishment the intelligence
agencies the doj have all done
everything in their power to make this
as bad as possible and it's not just the
doj it's not just the government it's
the big tech companies now removing
marjorie taylor green for what no covet
misinformation they said and dr malone
now marjory taylor green's not a
scientist but she is a leader in the
federal government they may not like
that she is but she is dr malone is a
scientist a dissenting one when you ban
descent that's the opposite of science
they're just proving to everyone the
problem is is bad or
as bad or worse than they realized and
and let's let's remember something when
like-minded people gather together they
tend to become more extreme right so it
was in the past it would have been a
matter of you know dr robert malone's on
twitter he's on youtube he's discussing
these things with other scientists you
can weigh what he says against other
people the truth can win out that way
right let's say someone's a huge fan of
audrey taylor green now they're just
gonna go watch her on rumble or view her
messages on getter they may not see
someone debating what they're discussing
with her they might grow even more kind
of close-minded in that direction right
they're they're reducing contact between
people of different ideologies because
they're just deciding certain ideologies
are verboten that they're forbidden to
be spoken
they're ending up segmenting and
segregating people off and that may
actually create more extreme echo
chambers in the long run and you know i
think
that this again i think because of all
the political considerations that are
happening right now i mean these
companies tend to be run by more
left-leaning people they have a more
left-leaning government in dc that they
are somewhat managing or dealing with
right now i don't think they think three
steps ahead when it comes to a lot of
this stuff right and i think again the
what you pointed out in terms of those
historical examples uh we've seen that
many times throughout history not only
with george washington after the
american civil war there was a long
process of reconciliation between the
north and the south that wasn't resolved
maybe for a hundred years i don't think
it was ever resolved after world war ii
i think that many of the allies you know
they kept actually a fair bit of the
german leadership of course many of them
were brought to trial and executed but
some of the german leadership was
maintained some a big part of the
japanese leadership was maintained and i
think they did that because they didn't
want to throw those societies into a
further civil war they didn't want to
make them feel marginalized and
repressed they wanted to say hey look
this war was wrong we defeated you but
we're going to bring you into the
community of nations now right they
wanted to make them feel included and i
think that mostly worked with germany
and japan and italy and these axis
powers
and i think that has generally been the
wiser path to to take here and i think
that
yeah i in a few days i imagine with the
january sixth anniversary we're going to
see a lot of mulling over this new york
times already said every day is january
6 now right you can't you can't move
past it you can't reconcile with these
people you can't try to come back to a
normal country they seem to be
wanting there to be some kind of civil
disturbance or war but it has no end
point and it has no goal either right
because what would that what does this
conflict entail even it's just a matter
of permanent grievance or resentment
divide and conquer i think it's
deliberate when you look at these echo
chambers they're not only created with
censorship they're created with the
algorithms that promote people from just
having their views regurgitated back to
them by people who have the same
political ideology and i think it's
meant so we do fight each other so of
course we don't really truly look at
what's causing our problems we look at
each other and see that's the problem
our common man our neighbor we should go
after him we should fight them because
they think not like me and again that
type of ideology is absolutely fascistic
and it's disgusting and it's something
we need to fight back on as much as we
can right now take a look at this uh
this tweet here from everyone's favorite
cnn personality brian stelter he says
watch how this twitter user mocks
reporters for talking candidly about the
trauma associated with the capital
attack i just quote tweeted it and wrote
trauma
the trauma
i like that i like the first uh reply to
it i think that's so pretty that's
perfect the first reply oh it's stewie
stewie from family guy the trauma okay
here's what you need to understand
if you are on the ground during these
like
riotous moments it can be stressful but
uh for many of us we've been through
tons of them i've been you know uh
brazil i think was one of the most
intense thailand was probably the
scariest because people were actually
killing each other there but to say that
in any way foreign conflict like there
there there are foreign war reporters
and conference conflict reporters much
braver than i'm much smarter than i who
have traveled to many countries facing
real dangers who don't have trauma and
many do don't get me wrong
for journalists in america who are not
on the ground to be explained discussing
their trauma over an event they did not
witness
i think it just goes to show you how
insane the whole system is getting but i
i want to keep the subject on on what's
going on together we have this story
this is really funny
uh from july of this year
the newest maga app is tied to a bannon
allied chinese billionaire getter has
existed as a chinese language social
media network linked to guo wengui
i say that it was unveiled as a new
platform by jason miller on thursday
they say
on tuesday guo and gwei an exiled
chinese billionaire who runs a chinese
language media network with trump
advisor steve bannon posted a video on
his g on his site g news reminding
viewers to back up their social media
posts on getter
saying i guess the site was going to get
wiped or something two days later donald
trump's former advisor jason miller
announced that getter a chinese language
site for dissidents opposing the chinese
communist party would soon launch as a
pro-maga free speech social media
platform now i don't know much about who
this guy is all right but there have
been a lot of people concerned about the
move together because of the association
with guo when way
i would like to show you this music
video from youtube
where it's only got 63 000 views it's
from october of 2020 and it's i it's
it's this guy is that who it is it's guo
is this i believe so yeah and he's on a
boat smoking a cigar and he's like ccp
you're over and he's doing like boxing
moves oh my gosh that you know what man
i can appreciate the uh uh the the
attempt you know culturally jamming and
all that stuff but uh what is it who is
this guy like what's what is this i
don't know if this could be considered
boxing moves but uh he's been a big
supporter of the hong kong movement and
of course he also hangs out routinely
with steve bannon steve bannon the scene
with him a lot other than that i don't
really know much about him uh but just
like you know anyone people should
obviously be looking into
who's who and who's controlling what
because again when you're running a big
tech social media company you have a lot
of power you got a lot of authority and
not a lot of people realize when
something's free you're usually the
product how
getters going to treat their product
their customer base is going to be
interesting because obviously this guy
has a lot of money i don't think maybe
money money
maybe money motivates him maybe it's
something else but uh i think only time
will tell i'm skeptical of of everything
to be quite honest uh with you
personally myself are you familiar with
this guy
no i honestly beyond the music video
oh you've seen this video before i i i
think he's he's known to be a character
but i don't i don't know anything
special about him i mean
i'll i'll say this there are a lot of
people talking about getter banning
people
banning you know like america first uh
they they reportedly banned the phrase
gruiper
and i saw that and people are like look
this platform is going to ban people the
same as all you know same as twitter and
other platforms so i went on getter and
i typed in did they really ban the word
gruiper to see if it was bad it posted
and people responded saying it's posting
so i don't think that they did ban it
maybe they temporarily did or something
happened however
their rules are the same as twitter for
the most part like obviously not the
community guidelines but the the terms
whether like we'll ban you if you if we
decide to
i believe getter absolutely will be
banning people 100 of course they will
they have to you can't have criminal uh
images you know like i don't want to get
too explicit on what those kind of
images could be but uh ian who's not
here tonight uh has experience when he
was working for minds of having to go
through these images which are like many
of which are explicitly criminal and you
have to remove them and to ban the users
however i think it'll go a little bit
beyond that i think getter probably will
ban people for you know i don't want to
say completely political reasons but for
fairly political reasons
i just think the difference is
twitter is obviously a left-wing
platform hands down their rules on
misgendering 100 percent left-wing
perspective the fact that it would ban a
conservative for holding a conservative
view well there you go the same is true
for all these big tech companies i think
getter wants to do the exact same thing
but just on the right here's the problem
the right typically likes to engage with
the left and challenge ideas the left
generally prefers echo chambers where
they're told what to think now i know a
lot of people on the left will will say
that's not true that's not true we've
already been through
multiple iterations of this where jack
dorsey himself said in 2016 left-wing
journalists were only following
left-wing journalists but right-wing
journalists were following both left and
right-wing journalists we've looked at
the ground news uh bias uh
charts on a variety of users and you can
see that people associated with the
right get their news from either the
right and the left maybe maybe a little
bit more the right and people on the
left it's 95 left-wing news sources
the left typically stays in an echo
chamber this is why when lauren bobert
was making fun of donald trump for
saying true nana shabbat of pressure the
left was confused and didn't know what
she was talking about because these
people just live in an echo chamber that
means twitter is perfect for the left
they don't want to leave their echo
chamber they want to be in it but getter
won't work for the right because the
right wants to engage with people yeah
does ghetto have a code of conduct and i
think a lot of people are asking the
question what guarantees do we have that
getter will stand up for the principles
of free speech obviously if there's
criminal speech that's a matter of
something that the authorities deal with
but but when it comes to free speech
when it comes to political discussions
when it comes to even criticizing the
ceo will that be allowed that's a very
important question that needs to be
asked i think it would be interesting to
talk to this ceo um i don't know if you
would be down to kind of have them on
but i would have a lot of questions and
guarantees and make someone even sign a
contract on air being like i pledge to
never censor free speech ever or i will
chop off my left hand
and uh or or whatever like i feel like a
lot of these companies they write
guidelines and they write terms of
service in that give them some wiggle
room to in the future if they feel like
they have to panic and censor or panic
and start moderating things they'll
start doing it like sub stack for
instance
i i don't think they've really cracked
down at all on on basically anything um
i think rogan and tim dillon were
talking about them cracking down on some
people well
within their within their service within
their guidelines they they say like
something like oh we don't we don't
allow hate speech or whatever and like
that's the most fabulous cat not getter
stack substance says that oh yeah i'm
reading getter right now they ban hate
speech well that's the thing that's like
the most nebulous category right that's
that kind of becomes whatever you decide
it is and so if you have that within
your terms of service i feel like you're
kind of leaving it like a valve for
yourself like if you feel like something
gets too like toxic or too spicy you can
like flip that valve and you can be like
okay that was in our terms of service
but the thing is they don't really
define that right so like you don't know
what their limits are or what they will
let me let me read this and i'll i might
have to be uh well i'll just read them
getter holds freedom of speech as its
core value and does not wish to censor
your opinions nonetheless you may not
post on or transmit through the service
any unlawful harmful threatening abusive
harassing defamatory libelous indecent
vulgar obscene sexually explicit
pornographic profane hateful
racially ethnically or otherwise
objectional material of any kind
including any material that encourages
conduct that would constitute criminal
offence give rise to civil liability or
otherwise violate any law rule or
regulation of the law laws applicable to
you or applicable applicable to the
country in which the material is posted
for example this may include content
identified as personal bullying
child abuse attacking any religion or
race or content containing video or
depictions of
oh man bad stuff yeah bad stuff bad
stuff we don't want to we'll get in
trouble um just let's just say isis
related stuff that's probably worse but
whatever oh well you know what screw it
i'm done with this beheadings there you
go there's the line we reserve the right
and our sole discretion to reject refuse
to post or remove any posting or other
user generated content including private
messages from you or to deny restrict
suspend or terminate access to all or
part of the interactive community at any
time for any or no reason without prior
notice or explanation and without
liability now i tell you this
that sounds
exactly if not
worse than twitter facebook youtube or
otherwise
the point is the people running getter
are the inverted political uh
perspective as compared to uh you know
getter is is inver is the inversion of
twitter effectively same as parlors
other platforms all that means is we're
going to have parallel
political discourse if you want to talk
about right-wing stuff they'll be like
oh that's not that's not hateful and
then on the left if you don't about
left-wing stuff if left they'll be like
yeah that's fine
getter is probably in my opinion
substantially less likely to censor you
for having his opinions
but they have the same rules so keep
that in mind yeah that's very vague
legalese language here that could be
interpreted and used in many different
ways especially if they have pressure
from the esg what is it the egs no the
environmental
social governance score yes g score
especially if they get pressure from
kind of institutional powers or bigger
players out there or advertisers it's
going to be interesting to to talk to
the guy who's running it i would love to
do that and i would love to ask more
serious questions and again have some
more kind of
uh you know things where we could put
things on paper and have guarantees
guaranteeing dude
they look man
they have to have these things because
for a variety of reasons exactly
namely they'd be banned from all the app
stores because of the silicon valley
monopoly on it so clearly getter's
trying to navigate this but you can't do
it you can't do it
it's not just the platform like getter
it's the fact that parlor got removed
over lies
gab was smeared and they went after
their infrastructure over lies
so getter is trying to play within the
bounds it's like
it's like you're in the matrix you know
they say in the matrix you're you can
you can sort of bend the rules but you
have to you're still bound by the same
rules that's what it is getter is still
within the silicon valley ecosystem
they're going to be dealing with the
same problems it'll be a little bit
better but for the most part
i don't know how much i don't know how
much better i mean mines might am i nds
it's always hard to say that word mind
is because people think you're saying
m-i-n-e-s um might be better but a lot
of people complain about their user
interface being really difficult to use
compared to like getter or other
platforms i don't i don't have all the
answers um i don't know
i i don't know i mean it might be a
matter of like there are people who talk
about you know crypto technology and
decentralization and things like that
that will
free people up to use these technologies
like i don't know like you can't have
like a giant signal group for like you
know a million people or whatever to
make it a social network but like people
use signal right now for like end-to-end
encrypted messaging with each other and
like you know there are technologies
that you
i don't know i guess it's going to take
a lot of building because up until i
would say about five or six years ago
even the silicon valley ecosystem was
fairly free like there was very little
moderation or censorship in the silicon
valley ecosystem up until i would say
2015 2016.
and so it's a new it's kind of like a
new problem that a lot of people are
dealing with and grappling with right
now right so
absolutely how do we look at luke how do
we navigate this how do we navigate this
landscape do we all trust some other
corporation out there do we trust them
or
or do we just go encrypted go anonymous
like it it's such a crazy battle that
we're even half having to deal with a
situation where scientists and members
of congress are having their voices
censored in favor of multinational
corporations with a criminal past they
use this term misinformation which is
like basically what they're trying to
say is the other person is wrong and
like you shouldn't be allowed to speak
if you're wrong and i'm just like how
can you have any conversation people are
always disagreeing with each other
someone's usually wrong about the facts
that's the nature of human human
dialogue
they might as well say pravda right that
would have been more convincing for me
well let's bring up this story we got
from timcast.com youtube and twitter
delete joe rogan's interview with
vaccine inventor dr malone the interview
regarding covet vaccines and mandates
was removed days after robert malone's
twitter was also suspended
there uh so i i don't think it was
posted by uh joe rogan though do you
guys know who uploaded this uh it was
malone himself right well when peter
mccullough was on he uploaded the full
interview on his youtube channel and
youtube took that video down so i don't
know if robert malone uploaded it on his
youtube channel alone had already been
uh
kicked off of twitter by time he went on
twitter but as far as the youtube video
the youtube video was uploaded in full
and then it was taken down so let me
tell you check this out so when this
when this episode on the of the joe
rogan experience dropped with dr malone
naturally it was getting huge huge uh
buzz everybody was talking about it they
just banned this guy and so i opened
spotify
normally when i open spotify it's like
the joe rogan experience front and
center trying to advertise it there was
nothing so i scroll around and i'm like
alright i'll hit podcast i hit podcast
nothing and then i'm like where's joe
rogan
i couldn't find him i was at first i was
just trying to search through like okay
podcast okay comedy nothing
entertainment nothing news
what
every time i used to open that before it
was like front and center watch joe
rogan so then i just had to manually
search joe rogan experience found it
went into his show profile found it and
played it that may be nothing maybe the
spotify algorithm was like tim we don't
think you actually want to listen to joe
rogan even though it's like the only
thing you listen to on spotify so we're
not gonna suggest it to you right now
but then i started seeing videos pop up
someone posted a video
where they were trying they were playing
a bunch of podcasts on spotify they even
played tim cast irl and then when they
opened up joe rogan with malone it
wouldn't load and he was like i can't
get it to play i don't understand so i
don't know if there is you know some
some you know something going on maybe
not but i got i just gotta
every time there's an accident or a
mistake it's or coincides whatever
it's only ever affecting this kind of
thing
when would people get banned oh it's a
mistake we didn't mean to ban you oh
yeah but how often is the our left
establishment people getting banned yeah
when that happens i just scream
illuminati
but again
it's also important not to jump to
conclusions but but it's also
there's so many coincidences that always
work in the favor of very powerful
people how do you draw the line here i
mean there also was a lot of internal
fighting between some spotify staff
members and joe rogan is there a
deliberate effort to undermine him maybe
we don't know but but the fact is like
these interviews the peter mccullough
tens of millions of peop millions of
people have been downloading it i think
i think last week it was 40 million
people downloaded the peter mccullough
interview how do you know how do you
know um those are the some of the
numbers released i think they released
the the stats on the malone it was 40
million on the malone one or the last
week this was uh no this is peter
mccullough oh
this is the number that i saw shared
around by a lot of individuals uh 40
million for me peter mccullough last
week those those videos are still up
they're still gaining a lot of views
robert muller and i don't know the exact
numbers um and and again we're talking
about it it's not unlikely it's very
likely especially with all the news and
buzz look
we've seen all of these stories about
spotify going after like spotify
employees demanding joe rogan be like
banned or removed and they won't do it
so
is is it is it absurd then to think that
these employees have just you know put
their thumb on the scale a little bit
i'll put it this way does there need to
be a concerted effort to go after joe's
uh content through infrastructure on
spotify no there doesn't there just
needs to be like a dude he's sitting in
his office and they're like hey we need
you to you know update that form you
know internally to make sure you know
the joe rogan show is going to publish
on time he goes okay i'll get to it and
then he laughs pulls out his phone and
starts playing you know yeah
angry well did you guys see today that
there was it was announced that uh
random house will not be publishing a
collection of norman mailer
because one of their junior employees
complained about one of his essays that
they thought was racially insensitive
and of course this guy was writing in
the 60s uh a gonzo journalist writing
all kinds of things he was mostly a left
left-leaning guy left-wing guy
but that's kind of what it takes in a
lot of these situations now is that you
have these large firms
they have employee revolts and it could
be a very small employee revolt and they
have to do something to appease them
right uh in this case they cancelled the
entire book one of the most famous kind
of 60s gonzo journalists
and i think they actually informed his
family like his surviving family they
wouldn't be publishing the book one of
the largest publishers but this is
happening all over the place i mean
netflix had an internal revolt over dave
chappelle now we learned at the end of
the day it was just a tiny number of
employees right it was a few dozen who
walked out is a massive company and yet
the company had to go through like you
know crisis mode internally i you know i
from what i understand it was quite
intense uh within that environment
because i think that unfortunately in a
lot of these environments they are not
um
you know they've inverted the the
leadership it's it's kind of ruled by
the angry or fearful minority right it's
not that the ceo tells the junior
staffer hey we're we're a company about
you know putting out these products that
people want to watch and want to see and
you don't have a veto over them but they
won't tell them that i feel like with
youtube and twitter facebook etc
they got the opposite message from uncle
ben dying you know you guys know uncle
benny said you know with great power
comes great responsibility and peter's
like oh you from now on uh so you know
facebook was like we have all of this
power but we'll be damned if we want to
take responsibility for anything that's
facebook twitter youtube it's all of
silicon valley what they don't first of
all there is political there's a
political agenda
for sure and those elements exist but
there's also cowardice in these
companies and when it comes to a lot of
the covid policy i think for the most
part it is fear of liability and there's
no liability when you're like hey man
look it's just what fauci said oh the
world health organization
so if you get someone like dr malone
who's like for the most part a lone
voice and he's saying things they're
like someone's gonna sue us and that's
you can look at a lot of their policies
fear of liability so what they're
basically saying is if we just ban
everybody who descends from like the
official narrative you can't hold us
responsible but they are the public
space these debates need to happen they
are banning dissenting scientific voices
and i'll show you this we have this from
the atlantic a smear piece on dr malone
but it does say it effectively says that
dr malone invented mrna technology they
say his two studies from night was in
1989 demonstrating how rna could be
delivered into cells using lipids
which uh which are basically tiny globs
of fat which could be used as a vaccine
or a vaccine delivery method these
studies indeed represent seminal work in
the field of gene transfer according to
ryan verbik a postdoctoral fellow at
ghent university in belgium and the lead
author of a 2019 history of mrna vaccine
development indeed malone's studies are
the first two references in verbiage
paper out of 224 in total so whether or
not you want to say he invented mrna
open it this way if like the first
ever in
inception of mr analogy comes from this
one dude or his team then yeah isn't
that inventing something it doesn't mean
he invented the core products it doesn't
mean he made like you know thomas edison
invented the light bulb they say did he
invent the fluorescent light bulb no
but you still say he invented the light
bulb right they're trying to make it
seem like he's got no grounds to
communicate they're lying they're
claiming he's not an expert there there
are these these government you know
funded scientists saying things like he
just played a minor role and has nothing
but
is he a phd
is he a doctor who specializes in
vaccines has he worked with the
government this regard okay then why are
we not allowed to hear what he has to
say
absolutely and i don't think uh big tech
is worried about lawsuits because what
where are you going to sue people for
this scientist provided some scientific
data get him sue him they can't do that
and if if anything the information being
provided here adds context and
information and allows people to have
informed consent one of the things that
dr robert malone brought up that i
thought was was very instrumental here
he didn't only talk about the profit
incentives of pfizer here he also talked
about bigger institutions financial
institutions like blackrock he talked
about the big financial systems that
have a lot of egregious power that along
with big tech are working in unison to
stifle out any kind of questioning of
their product that they're trying to get
you to take that is a scary situation
because you're giving people god-like
power and authority when you're able to
censor information
from the general public that is scary
that is terrifying and if everyone
everyone should know about this and i
think this is why we're seeing such a
huge scramble of people be like hey this
is absolutely terrifying i need to move
over get away to a totally different
platform where i could actually listen
to another side of the story here which
is absolutely critically important i
feel like joe rogan's viewership is is
more now than when it was when he was on
youtube yeah i was wondering you know in
in question the larger move from youtube
to to spotify and i think if he's able
to have a better closer relationship
with spotify which he looks like he has
he's able to get get away with a lot
more because if he was still on youtube
youtube would have taken the videos down
youtube is already taking the videos
down so so this is one of the ways that
he still was able to position himself in
a way where these videos are getting
tens of millions of downloads and views
but they can't be taken down by youtube
this is i think one of the
points of leverage that
rogan would have over spotify that
spotify is a much smaller company than
google right much smaller company than
than what alphabet or youtube can
provide
meaning that he's a much bigger asset to
spotify right i mean they they paid 100
million dollars to bring him over i
think what was the deal that was what
that was what uh i think wall street
journal reported
but you never know because it could be
like over 10 years you know what i mean
i doubt it's that long
but the idea is that he's going to be a
he's going to be a lot of revenue for
them as well right absolutely meaning
that
you know whatever pressures they have
within the company whatever pressures
they get externally from news media
whatever pressures they get externally
from government
if he's making them money and they have
their own infrastructure he has a point
of leverage over them and i think that
point of leverage is greater than what
he would have had over youtube given
this to the relative sizes of the
companies i saw this story
about a guy whose muscles are turning to
bone you ever hear about that stuff that
disorder huh you've heard about that no
i haven't where it's like um so normally
when you exercise your muscles the
proteins will break down and then your
body replaces it with you know proteins
and it grows stronger or whatever i'm
gonna i can't tell you exactly how it
works but um
apparently there are some people that
when the muscle breaks it's replaced
with calcium and just starts turning to
bone
that's kind of how i feel things are
going right now over time when somebody
like ages out or retires or moves on
from a position it gets replaced by an
an ideologue an immovable object that
creates rigidity and structural damage
that's why you're at the point now
where you've got like spotify big
company probably has a lot of money to
lose a lot of money to make but you get
a small portion of individuals who
appear
when a certain position opens up or when
a certain position you know someone
moves on from it the woke millennial
types or whatever gen z types come in
and then just that one person is like
bone and your muscle all of a sudden
you're struggling to move you can't
function properly and the system just
starts collapsing and failing
i saw that story i was like it kind of
feels like what's happening to our
society you know at a certain point that
they may just put a feeding tube in the
mouth of our culture and that the
government will just start subsidizing
and funding things out of fear of
collapse and economic failure and then
we're and then we're doomed and then
they'll give them a whole bunch of
fentanyl but that's my own personal
perspective but you made a very good
point because youtube could afford to
lose rogan spotify can't they invested
into him and i'll be honest when rogan
first moved on to spotify i was like
there's no way i'm downloading another
app i'm not doing this um you know i'll
look at the small clips that that he
releases but but with the debates with
the people that rogan had on robert
kennedy jr dr peter mccullar uh dr
robert malone having these important
conversations i can't miss it i had to
download the app i had to i had to sign
up for an account and and i had to
listen to it because it was the only way
i could and it's not just me it's a lot
of disenfranchised people who are asking
some serious questions that the
government can't answer right now as the
government has been caught time and time
again
lying putting their foot in their mouth
and absolutely not telling the people
the truth it's very evident right now
especially with cases surging that all
of their plans everything they did
hasn't hasn't worked at all so people
are left with some serious questions
rogan is helping those questions be
answered by presenting so much data and
information and letting them decide what
actions and moves to make for themselves
with informed consent like they should
have had from the very beginning let's
talk about how stupid all that cultural
stuff is getting we got this story from
cnn.com
patton oswalt defends his longtime
friendship with dave chappelle no he
didn't he apologized
patton oswalt was doing a show dave
chappelle was doing a bigger show after
patton oswalt's show ended dave was like
yo come in do a set we got a big arena
and so pat and oswalt did and you know
he was probably thinking patton oswalt
is he's famous but is he dave chappelle
no
so imagine you're like yeah you're in a
band and people have heard of you and
you maybe make six figures that's all
right you you're an opening act and then
all of a sudden like metallica at an
arena's like why don't you come in and
do a do a do a set you're gonna be like
dude an arena and you're gonna go super
excited but oh no oh no people are mad
at you now so patton oswalt posts this
photo where he's like look at me i'm
with my friend dave i've known him for
so long i'm so happy to be here and he
got attacked for it people started
saying that uh you know he was hurting
the lgbtq community and things like that
that he doesn't understand the damage
and the pain so he takes this other
photo on instagram where he's like he's
got like a yellow notepad and he's
writing down something looking pensive
in front of the mirror and he's just
like if i had known the hurt that i
would have caused
and he's like to think i would tell
other people they need to to learn oh
you know what grow a spine dude you took
a picture with your friend that's it
dave chappelle's a funny guy grow up
it's like he was punished and told by a
teacher write an essay why you're sorry
for having a friend for decades i mean
are you kidding me there's also a lot of
fake news spreading around this there
was a caption that dave chappelle
stopped to help this elderly lesbian
after her suburban broke down
that was fake news didn't happen just uh
going around with that photo just a meme
out there uh but but but it tells you
what kind of times we're living in where
a person who was friends with someone
for for decades is is apologizing for
taking a photo with them
you know what was funny is people
started going back into pat and oswalt's
uh old stand-up routine
and they found that patton had made very
like
i would say it goes beyond just being
transgressive it's almost like
mean-spirited jokes about transgender
people like far worse than anything that
chappelle had ever done this was just a
few years ago it was probably from 2014
or something people started posting that
on twitter like oh pat no you're so
embarrassed of you know dave chappelle
and you were doing this but i think
that's part of the rhetorical move you
have to make when you're in these
circles and that a few years ago if you
wanted to be like
a bully
you would be making like
anti-transgender jokes or making
anti-gay jokes or blah blah now if you
want to be a bully you got to be woke
right you got to be woke about it you
can still be like really hateful and
like spiteful towards people and you can
still basically be that bully but you're
going to have to do it in a different
direction i think that's what patent os
while he's orienting himself to where he
feels like his hollywood malou is now
which is that
you know dave chappelle is one of the
most popular entertainers in america but
he may not be that popular among a
certain subset of cultural liberals in
hollywood right the the one segment of
people in the news media and
entertainment who actually did take a
great deal of offense towards his his
comedy routines which i think honestly
if you polled most transgender people in
america i think most of them probably
wouldn't even have been offended because
most of them most of them were in good
taste and if you look at his routines he
makes fun of everybody and most of those
people don't get offended at it because
they understand the purpose and role of
comedy and levity in society right yeah
well that all seems to be going away i
guess except for the fact you know
netflix keeps signing more and more
deals with dave chappelle so let me just
say this
dave chappelle is being signed to
netflix because netflix has the data
netflix looks at who's watching dave
chappelle and they're like wow everybody
loves this guy let's give him more money
you see netflix doesn't make money off
of advertisements they make money off of
memberships if they book dave chappelle
to do a headline you know major special
on netflix and they give them how much
how much are they paying them it's like
tens of millions of dollars that's a lot
an employee leaked the information to
the general public yeah it wasn't like
five million it was a lot yeah man could
you you know what look i know dave's the
best of the best
and
it takes a lot of work to do these
specials but that much money for that
much work it's just like wow when you're
good you're good right but netflix is
thinking we are going to gain more
paying subscribers by booking the sky
than we will lose over any outrage we've
known this the the the leftist outrage
the the foe complaints it's like 30
people on twitter who won't stop talking
and they convince people like patton
oswalt he gets convinced oh everyone's
mad at me because he got like 30 people
constantly spamming him over and over
and over again reminds me of uh that
family guy joke where the guy's like we
got seven phone calls left last night
which means 70 billion people are upset
that's what it is
so dave chappelle is going to keep
getting booked we're gonna keep laughing
but
you guys i don't know if you guys saw
his last special
they're getting to him mm-hmm oh yeah
yeah he was defensive he he spends a lot
of i would say the past few specials he
spends a portion of the time sort of
defending himself against claims being
made against him right which is not
really where you want to be as a
comedian
you want to focus on the jokes on the
entertainment
it does sound like you know if i was him
i maybe i'd avoid some of those jokes in
the next special focus on some different
topics or just take some time off but
you know he's in that space now and i
think it's just it is again that small
minority of persistent angry people can
do this to you if you're in certain
social spaces even if the vast majority
of america i think understands that dave
chappelle's always been a little bit
risque he's always been a little bit
edgy um but he's there to make you laugh
he doesn't actually hate anybody he
doesn't try to make anyone hate anybody
uh but that's where a lot of these
spaces are now and that's why someone
like patton oswalt feels like he has to
apologize for a friendship with one of
the most probably one of the most
popular entertainers in the entire
country but they made to dave chappelle
get serious and that's what really kind
of affected everything and you you bring
up a small amount of people we have to
understand that these small amount of
people have a lot of institutional power
especially when it comes to the
corporate media literally promoting a
netflix protest saying that speaking
about it but but when you talk about
something and say there's going to be a
big protest here there's going to be a
protest here you're bringing attention
to it just to clarify though when we're
talking about a small amount of people
we're talking about you know uh
john you know at john 96 321 on twitter
it's these random profiles where they're
they have no followers they're not
necessarily bots i don't think they're
bots they could be sock puppets but
someone like patton oswalt you look at
his tweet about this and he's just
inundated with like you you can really
only see maybe like 30 to 50 tweets or
whatever like unless you really want to
scroll through everything and they're
like do better i can't believe you would
do this dave's hurting us and you're
like that's probably
30 to 50 people
out of the millions of people who follow
patent oswald how many are logging onto
twitter
clicking his post and then complaining
point zero zero one percent point zero
zero
percent but these people see these
things and they assume that wow
everybody's mad i better talk about
something making it worse dave chappelle
gets dragged into it he got serious and
there was a there's a cnn article
generated about this right there was
actually a cbc journalist a canadian
broadcast corporation journalist who
just resigned from her post
and she just wrote a subset piece about
why and one of the complaints that she
had was that you know you guys kept
running these articles about how people
find dave chappelle offensive why didn't
we ever go to the vast majority of
people who just like him and ask them
what they think right like
the media may be a small number of
people but it is a powerful institution
and they you know they're going to be
writing articles about you you know that
someone's going to be taking issue with
it even if it's a few dozen people at
netflix it's going to be portrayed as a
massive staff revolt you know that is a
headache in and of itself imagine
the narrative being that netflix knows
their audience doesn't like dave
chappelle that people are greatly
offended and don't watch it and they
booked him anyway that's the stupidest
thing i've ever heard no they're booking
him because he's bringing in members
he's bringing in money now for me i
don't have a netflix account ever since
they did that thing with the cuties yeah
i was like whoa
did they like double down on it it's bad
enough netflix has that show about uh
i don't even want to talk about this
show yeah a bunch of mainstream
celebrities talking about kids in adult
situations and that is putting it very
lightly i'm surprised they have that
show in the first place i don't know
anybody who watches to be completely
honest uh and like
for the most part you know we're not
like a staunch conservative suit wearing
tpusa kind of kind of place around here
you know we have like skaters
skateboarders rollerbladers punk rock
music
relative contrarians to a certain degree
and people aren't just being like oh
turn on you know big mouth on netflix
that's a show i like people are like
that's nasty like i don't know what they
were thinking with that show it's just
whatever but hey look
i'm not interested in watching a show
like that or watching cuties and if
they're if they want to keep doubling
down on that stuff i'm i'm not going to
be interested in being a member or
subscribing to that to a platform like
that you know what i mean
and and i think that raises a lot more
controversy especially with the cuties a
lot of people not signing up then
compared to dave chappelle that's only
from my perspective i could be wrong but
but again
they continue to work with dave
chappelle that's a big sign that
obviously the general public the a large
vast amount of people like his comedy
they want to hear edgy stuff they want
to hear stuff that lightens the
situation and when you're able to joke
about issues that
the establishment doesn't want you to
talk about if you're able to joke around
serious issues you're able to of course
make people relate to them better you're
able to of course get rid of a lot of
the stigma a lot of the hate a lot of
the negative energy around it i would
say comedians are absolutely crucial
towards bettering society bettering our
discourse and this is an effort to as we
were talking about earlier to destroy
that conversation and to create more
echo chambers i feel like almost the way
that comedy is getting around this a
little bit is um
a lot of these networks are bringing in
either foreign or i
think maybe more cultural you know niche
cultural subjects and actors and
producers to produce a lot of the same
stuff like
uh if you watch some of the foreign
programming on netflix i think you'll
find much kind of racier jokes or much
uh edgier more risque material than i
think what you might see in a day ship
i'll stand up and i think part of that
is that you're kind of getting out right
like if it's like if it's a foreign
produced if it happens to be
international comedy or international
cultures
maybe these same subcultures of
americans in these companies and
institutions and media give it a little
bit more of a pass right um which is
kind of funny like if you have to watch
like a korean drama to be able to like
see funny comedy about topics that
people want to be transgressive about
but uh it almost feels like you have to
do that sometimes there's a video on
youtube oh yeah that we bring up every
so often it is from august 9 2010
it is from the onion and it is titled
overcome stress by visualizing it as a
greedy hook-nosed race of creatures
oh my it's the onion
and
i can't even tell you what the jokes are
about because i play this
yeah i mean
i'm wondering if we can because it's on
youtube itself but it's a woman and
she's like when you have money troubles
visualize a greedy hook-nosed race of
creatures and it's very obviously like a
demeaning picture uh like a very
disgusting picture of a stereo like i
don't even i don't even want to i don't
want to get into it i don't get it the
point is i think people understand the
joke the onion's making here terrible
and this has got 1.5 million views
youtube still has it up this is what
comedy was just 10 years ago
for these networks now comedies turned
into like what's south park to the joke
with jimmy he's like hey what's the deal
with mexican food it's excellent cuisine
and i love it
like it's not even a joke
yeah yeah i mean actually it is kind of
funny when you're making fun of it well
one one show i really like is called
rami and i don't know if you guys have
seen rami um but basically it's about a
it stars an egyptian american uh who's
also the the writer and show runner and
you know he lives in new jersey and he
has an egyptian american family trying
to grow up in the states with kind of
these
cultural clashes and like he has an
uncle who's like very anti-semitic and
like constantly making jew jokes but he
like he still loves them even though he
kind of tells them that's like not right
to do that but like yeah that's the
cultural context you have to go to to
discuss something like that because like
it's not openly
like if the character was like white
american or like christian or something
like they wouldn't be allowed to have an
uncle who does that and like talk about
it and like actually normalize it and
let people like talk around their
differences because you have to actually
cast a character like that and have a
showrunner like that to be actually able
to approach these issues now because
there's so much sensitivity in talking
about cultural differences right if you
watch an older some of those older shows
like good times or the jeffersons
from the 60s and 70s they openly talked
about like racial stereotypes of like
whites and blacks between each other
that's how they broke down a lot of the
difference now it's just like you just
have to say the party line like you
break these things down by just beating
things into people's heads rather than
actually letting them be open about
their prejudices and talking them
through right i mean you look at uh
pat and oswald as a person and you look
at dave chappelle as a person and i'm
just like i kind of know who i'd rather
watch if i was given an opportunity the
you know the whiny crybaby who's like
i'm so sorry for the paint or dave
chappelle who doubles down granted he
got a little bit defensive on his last
special for sure but absolutely was like
i don't care you know what i mean i'm
gonna say what i want and i'm like yeah
that's that's more appealing to me it's
more honest well that's why they're
trying to get rid of him anyone speaking
truth is is deemed as a heretic in this
new kind of cult of woke and he's the
one willing to speak the larger truths
that a lot of people are thinking but
too afraid to say and we're pretty far
away from the days of george carlin
richard pryor and bill hicks but man did
those individuals make comedy great make
the first amendment something that a lot
of people stood behind and these larger
ideas that they represented that they
were able the effect that they were able
to have on people
was so important and i don't think
enough people attribute them to the
larger successes that we have as a
country as a nation as a culture uh
because of these individuals that stood
on their principles and in some
instances were even arrested for it so
shout out to
those individuals if you haven't heard
of them if you're someone who never
heard of these names look them up look
up their old videos and be
prepared to be astonished at the larger
truth bombs that they were dropping on
people that absolutely have awakened
humanity you have a list of names uh i
just uh listed uh three of them i could
probably think of some more what are
your favorite comedians i mean eddie
murphy too eddie murphy was also able to
go to places that a lot of people saw is
extremely controversial he doubled down
tripled down on it um especially when it
came to bill cosby um eddie murphy
called out bill cosby way before anybody
else uh in a very very important way
who's your guys's favorite linda um my
so my favorite comedians are not really
all that transgressive i never really
got into george carlin um but i feel
like every comedian has some form of
history of offensive jokes that they now
are walking back and i've always felt
that a lot of these comedians have made
a point of pulling up the ladder behind
them which i really hate to see i would
like to see some of them with some form
of character which is why i really liked
dave chappelle and i do hope this is not
getting to him or or or all these
comedians just be like shut up i don't
care i'm gonna make jokes yep
1990s
uh congress brought a series of people
to testify and grill them some of them
were the heads of labels for musicians
and artists recording artists others
were heads of like video game firms like
sega of america and so on and so forth
and universally what they would say is
like this is our freedom of expression
we don't think that this is going to
promote real world violence or real
world misogyny real world etc etc um you
know this is a place where people go to
escape so on and so forth
now those very same firms when they're
grilled by congress when they're grown
by the media typically they they concede
something right typically they back down
or they try to appease the the
opposition i think the culture of their
response has changed a lot in the face
of a lot of these protests and i'm not
sure what the difference is between now
and the 1990s but you'll see
you know tipper gore
bob dole joe lieberman bill clinton
these people all going after these
companies and the company's just
responding that it's our right to to be
able to speak freely and um you know
it's entertainment it's not real it's
not real life right yeah people in the
comment section are bringing up andrew
dice clay uh lenny bruce
yes uh norm mcdonald and arm also of
course uh bob saget and uh bob
yeah he right there i mean if there's if
there's something that's gonna raise a
couple hairs on your head it's
definitely the comedy of bob saget so
there's been a number of individuals and
and i think the reason why we go to
comedians is because they're able to
talk about these issues that so many
people are afraid to talk about and
there's not only a layer of kind of
controversy people are also talking
about patrice o'neill he was also really
just an amazing comedian mel brooks as
well but but they're able to to
you know hash things out through a way
that is bringing people together instead
of dividing them and if you want to push
the divide and conquer agenda
effectively you have to get rid of
comedy you have to get rid of satire
because it's one of the most effective
weapons against the establishment
against the ruling elite against the
very powerful because if you mock them
you take away all of their power and all
of their influence and we need more
mockery than ever
ladies and gentlemen
it is 2022. yes welcome to the first
show of the year on tim cast irl and
this is an election year it is a a main
election year 2020 was a the biggest
election year
2019 was the primary season 2018 was the
midterms
2021 is when everyone is just
zoned out they are they're beaten down
and tired 2022
the house
the senate
they're at stake
and we are there there are predictions
from many pollsters
many analysts of a red tsunami
now it's not just that people are sick
and tired of democrats that independent
voters are favoring republicans in the
double digits it's that gerrymandering
also just happened redistricting
happened and now there's an expectation
that all of these republican controlled
states because people were voting in
their local elections have set it up so
that republicans are more likely to win
combined with the fact that we have a
massive number of democrats retiring fox
news reports
surge in house democratic 2022
retirement announcements as 2021 comes
to a close
they say a trio of democrats in the
house reps uh stephanie murphy of
florida lucille roybal allard of
california and albio syres of new jersey
last week said they'll they'll retire at
the end of next year rather than run in
the 2022 midterm elections for another
term in congress the latest news brought
to uh 23 the number of house democrats
who are retiring or bidding for another
office we just got news that i think was
it bobby rush yeah what's the name is
also not going to be seeking re-election
there's actually an announcement from a
bunch of democrats who had lost in 2018
who are going to try and run again also
now announcing they're not going to
bother trying to run even though they
aren't in office something is happening
i think the democrats see the writing on
the wall nobody wants to be that losing
candidate so they're like what's the
point if you can't win do something else
a bunch of these democrats are running
for other offices you know in the state
governorships or whatever many are just
bowing out
i don't know man
red wave what do you think
it seems like if the election were held
you know next week that would be the
case right
the question i think is
uh can the democrats instill some
confidence on issues like what's
happening in the economy what's
happening with kovitt i think biden's
biden's mandate was basically normalcy
right can he create a normal political
social and economic environment
and i think part of that is like
getting past the pandemic part of that
is getting past coven 19 and i think
there's people within his political
party that really don't want to do that
they're not ready for that i think
they've inculcated a certain mindset
among a lot of the democrats on kobe 19
that it's just very hard to overcome
even though there are signs that i think
the body administration is pushing in
that direction i don't think they're
going to be able look i i hate to say i
know what's going to happen i don't
based on everything we've seen with the
polls
i think it's fairly likely the democrats
they know what's happening the writing's
on the wall but i want to show you you
mentioned joe biden i want to show you
this meme has been going around i did
not make this yeah it says 2020 biden
harris every single covet death is
someone donald trump murdered 2021 joe
biden eating an ice cream cone there's
nothing i can do jack
that's where we're at
joe biden the democrat look i think the
democrats uh voters they voted for biden
because they hate trump without trump
they have no identity that was their
whole rally their whole rallying cry was
orange man bad and now there's nothing
going into the midterms you've got
parents who are livid you've got an
economy in shambles you've got joe biden
saying there's nothing we can do at the
federal level well i'll tell you this
you you vote in the primaries and get
rid of all the established republicans
bring in some populists who believe in
america they'll bring your jobs back
they'll secure your borders they'll make
sure the country's economy is getting
back on track
i don't necessarily have anything to say
about an individual candidate but i'll
tell you the democrats ain't gonna do it
they have become the party of big
business massive corporate wealth you
take a look at people like hassan [ __ ]
who is one of the most prominent voices
among progressives and he supports the
government mandating you be administered
a private product from a massive
multinational unaccountable corporation
with no liability protections and i
don't care what the dude says he claims
about you know i don't care what his
claims are about supporting universal
healthcare and nationalization of big
pharma it's like dude you're sitting
here right now telling us that you want
the government government to be able to
mandel mandate a private product to be
administered to people if they want to
engage in public in public
accommodations if they want to be able
to use these things i'm sorry this is
what the modern left is this is you know
he he's one of the one of the if not the
biggest political commentator on the
left and that's what young leftists
follow support for that kind of system
not always not everybody who watches
likes him i get that but that to me is
insane i can sit here all day and say
that a lot of trump supporters are in a
cult and and you know worship the ground
trump walks on i can say that donald
trump is he represents the worst of
american culture in my opinion i can say
he had a lot of really good policies and
as much as a lot of people didn't like
him for who he was he was actually
bringing factories back he was trying to
secure america's borders and bolster our
economy so people whether they liked him
or not they voted for him there's
certainly a lot of people who love him
we're not getting that from the
establishment the democrats are offering
us nothing other than trump is bad and
people they're like i don't know
anything about that at the point trump's
not the president the economy is in
shambles my life is not going well i'm
tired of the lockdowns they just brought
back mass mandates down the street
because we're on the border of the
county and it makes literally no sense
and i'm like these people need to be
stripped of all power they are
completely insane and that is the
democratic party and the republican
establishment
so one of the things i noticed what are
the things i think the democrats really
should have done and then i have a
question for you um is
they should have run on getting rid of
trump because that's pretty strong
platform and the first thing they should
have done is turn and said we have to
have issues that we're fighting for not
just stuff that we're fighting against
because it's not a winning strategy in
the long term they had to have known
this i just don't think they were
thinking anywhere near far enough past
stage one and then for you in your meme
here you use the term mass formation
psychosis and i haven't really been able
to get into this but i keep seeing it
can you like unpack that for us well i i
i just use that phrase in reference to
uh it's a cult it's a cult that that's
formed oh okay i've long said that
they're a chaotic and destructive force
the left i don't like the idea of uh
i've actually been critical of those
it's critical race theory over and over
again because what's happening on the
left isn't just critical race theory
that's why i like to say wokeness or
something it is
all of these things are just an amalgam
of contrarian i hate the other that's
our identity
you know it's really funny you look at
reddit you look at the comments and
they'll say all the trump cult they just
hate the other side it's like who are
you listening to who are you watching
because if you watch like i don't know
stephen crowder one of the most
prominent independent conservative
voices he's actually making arguments
right he doesn't just hate you in fact
he tries to debate you to bring you on
and convince you to change my mind who
are they actually listening to oh cnn
brian stelter jake tapper cuomo well
he's gone things like that mass
formation psychosis in my view i'm just
referencing all of these people
they they their world was was was
getting crazy social media was crazy
they latched on to this narrative that
trump was the cause of all of it and you
were mentioning something earlier that
michael malus said they thought donald
trump was the was the river when he was
actually the damn yeah i messaged you i
said that one of the most insightful
things that i think i've ever heard a
modern political commentator say is
something michael mal said and that was
they thought that
um trump was the river wait what was it
that he said they thought trump was the
river but he was actually the damn yes
so that means that he was kind of
holding back this huge wave of populism
he was really just the tip of the
iceberg which is something that they
weren't counting on and now i think
they're seeing the other side of that
when donald trump goes on stage with
bill o'reilly and he gets booed by his
audience it's not a cult right it is it
is angry people they are america first
individuals they are fed up with all of
this i think the democrats know all of
this all right all right hot shots pop
quiz name
a democrat who could win a presidential
election who's relative like right now
name somebody i've been thinking about
that ultra yeah
michelle obama yeah michelle michelle
obama oprah actively right now in
politics right now in politics who's
who's a prominent oh sure trump was
never in politics either right trump
trump was planning on running
he ran a number of times right he lost
right before yeah it's so i'll be the
first to say i've stated before i think
michelle obama i don't think i don't
think she can win at this point i do not
think so really but obviously michelle
obama because if you take a celebrity
and you know put them in a position they
might get the votes but like i'm i mean
like who among democrats right now i
mean oprah's a tv show they don't have a
bench right right they have not
developed because their leadership is so
old
they have a young generation but those
young generation are way too young right
like people in their early 30s are not
going to be running for president right
so they don't have that middle layer of
people of kind of like statesman and
states women who could just jump into
the presidential spot and you know the
typically in this scenario you'd line up
the vice president but nobody likes the
vice president yep she's even more
unpopular than joe biden is right yeah
actually i think that flipped recently
oh did it okay yeah yeah i think i think
his approval dropped below her as it's
so bad that's really bad worse oh my
gosh
so i
i think come in 2022 the democrats have
awakened to the reality without
trump they have nothing well look i and
the right doesn't need trump i i live in
virginia i did some reporting on the
election
and at one point i got a mailer from the
democratic party of virginia about glenn
younkin the republican candidate and it
was full of trump quotes about glenn
younkin it was just talking about how
trump has endorsed junk and how much he
likes junkin didn't say anything about
the democratic candidate didn't really
say anything about yunkan himself just
talked about trump
mcauliffe the democratic candidate for
governor who lost kept talking about
trump every other line out of his mouth
was trump trump trump trump
that's their motivating fact right they
they you know it's the dog running after
the car they caught the car
trump is gone but
that's still their campaigns that's
still their focus is trump and the
problem is that that might work for the
hardcore democratic faithful but a lot
of those people in between the hispanics
the wall street journal had a really
good article about hispanics are now
like split between the parties uh we had
rui tahera on our podcast on
inquiremoor.com who was one of the
emerging democratic
majority author whose thesis has been
badly misinterpreted he was saying it's
not true that just because you know
america is going to have many more
minorities the democrats are
automatically going to win because
hispanics care about issues like
you know basic bread and butter issues
and they care about they don't want to
defund police they don't want kind of a
radical social agenda you know these are
very middle middle-of-the-road type
voters and i think these
middle-of-the-road type voters you know
just being against one person for the
rest of their life donald trump is not a
motivation to vote right getting things
basically working in their lives is the
motivation to vote and the democrats
really aren't doing that when there's a
permanent coven coveted emergency they
just can't overcome right and they have
to either admit it's what they're doing
doesn't work and that they've wasted
your time or that it's over and they
lose that emergency you know power that
fear factor i'll tell you i'll tell you
what i care about for one the economy is
trash inflation is through the roof and
we need to get this country working
again the current policies are our
disaster but i also want to mention the
insanity of it all so this past weekend
i was with my girlfriend we went to go
with sushi
we walk into this restaurant which is i
kid you not the the the restaurant was
probably about as big as two of this
studio room so that's like you know 15
by 35 the restaurant was probably like
15 by 50 or something there was a table
about 10 feet away from where we were
standing we walk up the stairs and
there's a waiter he's wearing a mask and
he sees us and he goes you have masks
and we were like no we don't have any
like there's the masked medic literally
came back the day before yeah it was at
5 00 p.m on december 31st so we're there
on like you know new year's day or
whatever like you know we're gonna grab
some sushi like no i don't have any and
it's like well you need to wear them and
then i look around and i see 20 people
sitting down and i'm like nobody's
wearing a mask
like they're all sitting here and they
were like well they're sitting down and
i was like all right can i can we just
sit down like there's a table literally
10 feet in front of us and he was like
yes but you have to have a mask and i
was like
but no one is wearing one like there's
they're all talking they're all laughing
they're all eating and they're not
wearing masks but i was i was like okay
no i get it we'll sit down and he says
fine but if you get up you have to have
a mask so he hands us masks we say okay
no problem i don't care and then he's
grabbing the menus to take the two
seconds to walk us to our seat when all
of a sudden behind the counter to my
right i hear someone yell put the mask
on wow and then i was like we're gonna
sit down like no you have to wear it
what and then i was like but i can take
it off when i sit down they're like yes
and i went are you serious and they all
all the staff go yes and i was like dude
i am out of here man
like
there is a certain degree to where when
all this started they said mask mandates
i'm like i get it man
masks stop you from spitting on people
they don't stop the aerosolized virus my
understanding but spinning on people can
also transmit so that i get that makes
sense to me but when you're in a
restaurant and they're like take this
disposable mask you're going to throw
away in 30 seconds we don't actually
expect you to wear it while you're here
but you have to pretend to be doing
something for some reason i'm like dude
why are you doing this this is going
beyond insane
and that is something that frederick
county and uh there's a couple counties
in in maryland are doing new york has va
has vax or mask as a statewide policy
now and i'm like look if you want to go
to a record store i i understand that
argument but if you don't have logic
behind your policies then you are
cowards you are insane and this doesn't
make any sense so i'll tell you this if
the democrats are going to keep running
on ridiculous and not to mention
polluting policies that that are just
insane we're environmentalists we don't
like global warming but take this piece
of trash you're gonna throw away and not
actually wear like they handed me
garbage they literally hand me garbage
to sit down and throw in the trash yep
that was it for no other reason yeah so
you know we did we got in the car we
drove only a few minutes because we're
on a it's a border county and then there
we were eating sushi with no mask like
what is wrong with these people man
that's what i'm sick of i'm sick of the
democrats like aoc she's in new york and
she says kathy hoechel maybe she could
give rhonda santa some tips oh is that
true aoc you flew down to miami to party
with no mask on
while saying that ending the mask
mandate in texas was going to get people
killed and then you think ron desantis
needs tips yo you're going down you
don't believe in your own policies but
the cult members in your state don't
read they don't pay attention and they
vote for people like you i'm sick of it
man vote them all out but i'll tell you
this if you don't vote in the primaries
you will get a bunch of neocon crackpots
who the first thing they do is they go
now that we've been elected we're going
to stand by the mandate of the american
people and re-invade afghanistan and
great that's exactly what the people
want but just really quickly you don't
get it the the masks work so well the
first time the covet policies worked so
well the first time that we just have to
do them again okay you know you know
what i was thinking maybe maybe it's
because we only wore two masks maybe we
should wear four that's right yeah
well i think you brought up a good point
though and that the republicans could
fall into the same trap now which is
that they could see that democratic
governance is unpopular they could see
the economic and public health
emergencies kind of unpopular
they could ride that wave into power and
then they could just do nothing right i
mean that's kind of what they did uh
in 2018 with healthcare right they
didn't have a healthcare strategy for
the affordable care act they were the
dog running after the car they were
saying repeal obamacare or peel
obamacare said that for basically eight
years once they got in the position to
do something about health care they
didn't have any ideas uh they basically
said it's too complicated and they
couldn't agree on anything right um the
question is are they actually going to
have a governing agenda or they're going
to end up right back in the same place
with parties trading places and not
actually being able to to resolve some
of these things and move forward
yeah i have absolutely no hope in the
republicans to me they're going to be
absolutely lame ducks they're going to
be sitting on their hands and they're
going to allow a lot of these egregious
behaviors to happen just like they did
from the very beginning of this so to
expect them to do something different is
absolutely naive big tech monopoly
lobbying has a hold of a lot of the big
conservative base they're absolutely
futile to actually challenge the
establishment and the few ones that do
they're the ones that get hit they're
the ones that get slandered they're the
ones that get uh you know booted from
their committees exactly you know the
progressives just run amok in congress
so you know what's happening right now
is also absolutely crazy when we look at
the raw numbers especially with people
on twitter making the case that you know
there's huge numbers of cases in florida
going up and only concentrating on that
and ignoring the fact that there's a lot
more cases in new york and new york of
course represents the state that did the
most what's the correct answer here
uh it's a very complicated one it's not
an easy one but i i would end by saying
you shouldn't have all of your faith all
of your cookies and that republican
basket because you're going to be let
down or or just vote in the primaries
and make sure you get rid of the
establishment well here's here's the new
narrative this is what we get we got
this from the guardian u.s could be
under right wing dictator by 2030.
canadian professor warns
canadian political scientist warns an
op-ed of trumpest threat to american
democracy and possible effect on
northern neighbor i love how their like
right-wing dictatorship is coming and
they show a picture of trump i got to be
honest and i'm not trying to be mean
not not i'm not entirely convinced
donald trump will even be alive in 2030.
eight years from now he'll be in his
late 80s mid to late 80s okay i mean
that's well above average life
expectancy for uh on the average
american adult male but maybe i gotta be
honest trump is pretty spry so he could
be but under a right-wing dictator see
i'll tell you what they're doing they're
just trying to generate fear to scare
the left to get them to rally around
something but i i tell you a mannequin
will not be trump donald trump is that
big imposing figure the left coward and
feared and now they're like but look at
this invisible specter of right-wing
trumpism and it's like yo i don't know
what that is i don't see anything there
it's hollow your argument is trash i
mean they'll have to they'll have to
betray whoever comes next as worse than
trump right because it's like
it's like you have a television series
and they're like oh the next season's
nowhere near as exciting you know it's
going to be boring actually like no
one's going to watch it right they're
using the same principles as like as
like entertainment or infotainment
um
which you know i i think
it's not even a a choice between whether
they really believe this or they don't i
think a really good like propagandist
believes what they're saying right like
i think a lot of people on the left have
have convinced themselves that democracy
is like five seconds away from
you know disappearing uh that allows
them to protect that same image the rest
of of the planet i think okay you
correct they're going to have to say
that whoever comes next is worse than
trump the problem is take a look at this
article from the independent
trump's denial of climate change
represents worse threat to humanity than
hitler says activist noam chomsky look
at this dude man whoa yikes bro
noam chomsky has that famous uh video
where it's like in the 70s and he's
defending free speech even for those who
disagree with now he's become this like
disheveled old
crackpot communist
but here's my main point if they're now
saying in more ways than one that trump
is worse than hitler here's an article
from newsweek a woman tweeted hitler was
better than trump and twitter won't say
whether she broke its rules
if they actually believe that
then
then what do they say about the next guy
like he's the antichrist or something
did you guys watch this netflix movie
don't look up yes yeah okay i liked it
well okay yeah i thought it was a fun
movie in terms of being watchable and
actually someone i had worked with in
the past david sirota helped co-write so
i you know i'm not trying to be mean
about it but like one of the things the
movie really gets wrong
is that okay so the plot of the movie
for those i haven't seen is that a comet
is heading towards the earth it's going
to be there in six months and the news
media and politicians spoiler alerts ah
just in case oh yeah it's it's it's a
still new movie all right my i'll do
mild spoilers i won't give anything too
much weight but basically the the the
arc of the plot is that the media and
politicians don't take it seriously like
they don't really care that comet's
going to head towards the earth and
destroy everybody
and you know i watched that and i just
thought to myself it it doesn't have any
bearing on reality because like if there
was a comet heading towards the earth i
think cnn would have like a comet
hologram
you know i think they would have 25
watch they would have like 25
intersectional takes on the comet every
day like what the comet is going to do
to women to minorities like you know
like
like the media the media in this country
is driven by fear it's not always fear
of stuff you really should be all that
scared of i would say but like they
understand that fear sells a fear
against clicks and there's absolutely no
way that they will
uh pass up the challenge of an actual
world-ending disaster which by the way
climate change is bad in many ways but
it's not actually a world-ending
disaster like the planet will still
exist the ecosystem will see like this
humans will still exist it will change
uh a comet with and
that's a really good point i can imagine
don lemon doing you know comet watch and
they have like they're the sidebar and
it's like miles you know time till hits
the earth and like miles traveled and
then there will be like a special
presentation where they like look at the
sky and they have like a reporter on the
ground we're here in new york at the top
of the empire state building you can
look up you can start to see it forming
they would never stop they have panels
discussing like no no they would have
reenactments they would have animated
reenactment reenactments of people dying
and getting obliterated they would have
a death counter how many people are
going to die how many people are going
to suffer every every segment would be
yelling at the president mr president
how dare you not blow up that comment
you know you have to do this immediately
like it would be five alarm car fire we
know that because that's what happened
with cope at 19 right which was far less
severe than a comet strike in the air so
i just you know it's a fun movie i think
it was an enjoyable watch but i do think
that the writers kind of just missed it
like that's that's not the way the media
operates there's a meme i saw where it's
the the woe jack like face all happy and
it's got the full political compass over
the face
looking at the movie saying wow it's me
it's proving me right and making fun of
my political rivals like the movie made
fun of literally everyone that's why i
thought it was all right but it was
obvious what the narrative was the
message was that climate change is
serious the scientists are warning us
and no one takes it seriously but i
think you're right i think
the fear is is too juicy for them to
give up but there's also a lot of people
desensitized as you were just talking
about
a few moments ago people are angry
people are fed up i absolutely believe
that's the case especially with covet
especially with just how
horribly the government messed up and
how you would argue that every step of
the way they made the situation that
much worse there's a lot of evidence to
suggest that but
at a certain point i think enough people
say hey i'm just sick of this this is
not going to affect me there's only so
many times you could lunge out and
scream boo at somebody before they're
like
okay this doesn't really work at all and
i think this is why
there is a victory that we're having
here that we need to note and that is
that news corporate news media
viewership by and large has been going
down by the years and it has continued
to go down and i think that's a huge
victory and i think people are just
getting so desensitized so out of touch
with it or they're just going on zoloft
and other ssris but but but there's also
a small section of that but the majority
of people are saying this is not scary
anymore it's like a halloween ride that
just you know loses its its factor after
going on it so many times it's called
yeah it's like it's a form of bias that
like probably all the news has which is
called negativity bias right like
they're always trying to tell you how
the world's like going hell in a hand
basket right and at a certain point why
does someone want to sit there and watch
that every single day even in the most
trivial circumstances you know finding a
woman in central park who's rude to
somebody or something and putting the
video on national news like right at a
certain point someone's gonna be like
why am i watching this over and over
like why why am i getting this distorted
view of the world why are they trying to
make me miserable i don't i don't think
that's it because i think you can you
can uh levy some of that criticism
towards us as well you know we sing we
see things in the news and we we
highlight like wow we think this is
pretty bad and something needs to be
addressed
to be fair though you know if you even
look at some of the stories we did over
like to the start of this show like joe
rogan leading the charge to to go
against censorship is fairly neutral
censorship is bad but people fighting
back is good so we we try not to be
always very negative but i think we're
very negative however i think cable tv
is driven specifically by editorial
demand for negativity which is it's
different from here like we have actual
we we're just we're people with opinions
before we start the show we sit down i
say like hey luke what have you seen in
the news what do you think is important
and luke's got a bunch of stories like
riots are happening here or this happens
and then we'll try and figure out what
we think is like the most important
thing that we should talk about what
what what matters most to people in
terms of what's happening
for me i thought the joe rogan thing was
big because such a big celebrity to push
back against censorship and i don't see
that as a negative for the most part
kind of just is
but cnn we learned this thanks to real
journalists like project veritas when
you get that cnn producer saying that
covid deaths were gang-busters for
ratings they put that big old thing
death counter on the on the tv think
about how despicable that is man and
celebrating and being happy about it
that they were able to get ratings
because of that fear that's another
layer of it that really needs to be
understood by people who consume media
they should understand what they're
getting and who they're getting it from
and when they're getting the news from
cnn you don't want to know who you're
getting it from when you find out holy
cow i mean i think news media always has
to address problems like you know i made
a couple of documentaries with fox over
the past year in different locations but
i think in terms of addressing the
problems you should also be addressing
solutions like you should also be
constructive you should be trying to
figure out like how do we solve this
like what are what are people doing
about it and i think the difference
between
people sitting around talking about
problems like we are and what cnn does
is like cnn doesn't care if there ever
is a solution to the problem cnn is just
there to tell you that everything's
horrible and you need to be addicted to
us to keep telling you how horrible
they're incentivized to make it more
horrible because when they do they get
more viewership because of that so and
and i think this is in response to a lot
of their coverage which is in my opinion
leading to some real life harm
i gotta tell you man
you constantly just watching what's
going on you know people have asked me
like man it must must get to you
sometimes and i'm like you know it's
it's not the news it's it's it's it's
more like the personal aspect when i'm
when i'm reading stories about news
policy worldly affairs that's not a big
deal but when i read about
incessant behaviors that's really um
it it it's it's black pilling when you
see like hey we're experiencing the same
problem again because people just do the
same thing over and over again it kind
of feels like a human macro level
problem that's in intrinsic to humans
like why do you why do people in new
york keep voting for ocasio-cortez well
they don't read the news they don't
watch the news they get their their
information from word of mouth they
don't pay attention
so they're trapped in this cycle and i
don't see that as ever changing i really
don't until the maybe the pot boils over
and knocks off the stove or something
for the time being aoc can say like oh
we got to have mask mandates you know
texas is killing people and then go
party in miami because she knows her
constituents won't read the news and she
gets away with it so that that's the
kind of thing where i'm just like man
all of this could stop
and we could make a minecraft channel
and just talk about you know the what i
don't even think about minecraft
creepers creepers yeah yeah the creepers
oh they're getting to us you know it's
oh you know but instead it's just like
the same thing every day we've been
talking about censorship for a decade
and it's been getting worse we've been
talking about you know many of these
cultural issues the banning of comedy
for for five six seven years and it just
keeps getting worse and at a certain
point it's like are people going to keep
behaving the exact same way is anything
going to change or do we are we stuck in
a loop
but maybe maybe not a loop maybe it's a
downward spiral that eventually just
reaches the point where we're spinning
so fast
i still i still think the fact that
we're still here is a victory the fact
that against all odds the algorithm
changes the tweaks the demonetizations
the just deliberate efforts to stop any
kind of independent speech the fact that
there's still some resilient people out
there building infrastructure building
their own bases is is a victory in
itself and we're very blessed to still
be here and still be able to still keep
up the fight in some kind of way sorry i
cut you off there
no i was just saying that like let's
remember also like we're talking about
this covert emergency state like
the world came together governments came
together business came together
pharmaceuticals came together we all
like dramatically altered our lifestyles
in ways that we'd never done before
people were you know doing these masks
people were social distancing there's
lockdowns all this happened and like you
said we're still here right they
developed vaccines
most people have gotten through this
thankfully this disease is actually not
very harmful children at all people are
slowly waking up to that um we survived
this much better than we have past
pandemics right it's nothing like sp
spanish flu so on and so forth and i
think that that's like a positive thing
right like we can't get too down on
ourselves and say that oh america
reacted to this so poorly you know we're
so stupid you know take the don't look
up view of the united states we can also
look at the fact that we
actually the average american did tons
of stuff in response to this that we had
never done before we a lot of us did
kind of rise to some kind of calling
even to some of these policies were
misguided
um and we're all still here like we
survived this and we're gonna survive
this i'm actually fairly optimistic on
on where we're going in the future i
just feel like after seven or eight
years of the same things happening and
over and over again my what i mean to
say is the thing that's annoying and
frustrating doing this job is that you
hear the same stories on repeat you know
sometimes they're slightly different
sometimes they're just regurgitated and
it's you just kind of wish people would
learn and change their behaviors but i
think the issue is that humans are um
human civilization is is emergent it's
constantly in flux with younger people
aging and dying and younger and then
younger people coming in taking over so
you end up with people like uh vosh for
instance who
comes on this show and said he didn't
know anything about the obama
administration because he was just a
teenager
but now he's a major you know force in
political commentary on the internet not
the biggest channel in the world but
he's fairly large he gets a lot of views
and he's having a conversation about
politics when he wasn't around for what
obama had done and biden as well
so he's lacking that experience that
makes it impossible for humanity to to
effectively learn in a sense and not not
completely just in some areas however i
i do think that
people are going to get to a point where
they just slam the table and say i'm mad
as hell i'm not going to take it anymore
and that's why i think democrats are
resigning and retiring or planning to
retire in huge numbers but let's go to
super chats yes if you haven't already
we have a pinned message just smash the
smash like smash the like button give a
little give it a little tap it's not
supposed to make sense
there's an old advertising technique
when you present something that is is
absurd to the brain they're more likely
to notice it ah
yeah there's this thing i watched where
it shows like an old ad from the 50s and
there's a woman on a swing with three
legs what because it was like they
wanted people to have it stick in their
brain anyway smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
if you really do like it and go to
timcast.com become a member if you want
to help support our work we got a bunch
of new merch we got wacked shirts yeah
the the money sign whacked you can check
out a little skull it's really cool
that's at the timecast.com store and you
can go to
invertedworldbook.com if you want to
pick up tim cast's first book it's
mysteries murders ghosts paranormal and
a serial killer just tales of the of
intrigue and we're gonna have a members
only segment up around 11 or so p.m for
all you guys let's read some super chats
first super chat i can't read your name
because
uh youtube blocks it says it's the
establishment versus the rest of us
yup the problem is when you have young
people who aren't familiar with what the
establishment is doing or has done they
end up supporting it and then you're up
against young progressives who are just
brainwashed into thinking populists are
the bad guys even though they're
somewhat populous i don't know
all right
seth says why did nunes resign do you
guys know why nunes resigned
really he resigned because he's going to
be uh yeah with trump social yeah devin
nunes is going to be running donald
trump's social media yeah uh the trump
social platform and my understanding is
he believes that he will be more
effective in helping get the word out
and helping grow the trump movement or
just the populist right by working with
social media and and you know getting
past all the censorship
joe master says good for joe rogan i got
suspended from twitter for being mean to
keith olbermann lol huh you see what you
know what's funny about that is that
keith olbermann is one of the meanest
people just
ever he's just nasty terrible like you
you got banned how is he not banned
right i don't know if you get either you
guys have written you interacted with
him luke um
thankfully not uh it would be
crazy if i did especially with how
flippant and emotional he he gets and
and illogical but uh there's a lot of
people who spread a lot of medical
misinformation the ceo of pfizer said a
lot of things that were absolutely not
true on twitter and he has yet to be
held responsible
rachel maddow dr fauci so many of these
individuals lied through their teeth
they need to be held accountable for
they haven't it's crazy rachel maddow
has spread so much diss and
misinformation it is it is is laughable
if if misinformation was a quarter she
would be able to go to the arcade you
should be able to play for a very long
time that's my best analogy i could come
up with uh it's just it's insane there's
like a video that i tweeted about and
it's funny you know what i love i love
on twitter i just post like it's all ish
post it's all like just trash garbage
posts and the funny thing is when the
media takes the bait and runs stories on
them takes it seriously i tweeted rachel
mad out pl should be banned for this i
got my opinions from twitch like i was
making a joke about left-wing streamers
supporting massive private corporations
controlling the flow of speech right and
then all of a sudden i have people like
leftists tweeting like tim support
censorship
well if you're not smart enough to see
through i get it clever all right all
right all right everybody
congratulations you are correct
we have uh woot do for you langoliers
greg the langoliers rocco rocco the band
langoliers rock rocco um saint miles
langoliers kiwi langlaires that's right
the reference i made earlier in the show
as to why ian is not here was a
reference to stephen king's the
langoliers couldn't figure that out i
was like why are people saying did you
know that luke i thought you were
talking about lost
yeah see i that's why i was saying like
i don't think you knew what you were
talking about the langoliers they
they're sleeping in a plane they wake up
and everyone's gone and like their
clothes are all there the plane went
through a rip in the time space
continuum and they're basically
time moves forward and the past is eaten
by langoliers and they get like the the
whatever the thing that moves time
forward they go through and so they're
trapped in a past where everything's
frozen like nothing moves everything's
stale
and then they see the language start
destroying everything so they're like
quick get in the plane and they fly the
plane and then the the dude turns the
pressure down so everyone passes out
again and then the plane they wake up
and they're
back in reality or whatever yeah i like
stephen king man he's kind of a creepy
dude but he's got you know he's got some
good stories you know good author
yep uh patriot paladin says stephen
king's langoliers
neokashi says i i see you've seen the
langeliers yeah the the movie they did
was from uh a very long time ago i don't
know if you guys ever saw it was like
the 90s
noise says doing my part i'm building
decentralized social media
defluencer on github live streaming
videos comments blog and more very cool
yeah that's one of the nonprofits that
we're working on for this year is the on
foundation uh ian and many others are
working really hard and that is to
create decentralized social media so
that you will own your own website
social media system no one can ban you
but the individual pieces of the
infrastructure
and then
you know you'll you'll be able to uh
network with everybody without getting
banned
are you are you just yawning luke i
don't know if you're gonna yeah i'm
yawning
yeah fall asleep raymond g stanley jr
says tim so you're telling us that last
year was an off year that means this
year as an on-year all i can say is hide
your kids hide your wife
yeah everyone's gonna get banned man be
fun all right a million one comments
about the langoliers langoliers
langoliers
roberto lara says tim don't forget the
large hadron collider is getting powered
up this year with twice the power what
there's already political memes good and
cringed in
in culture groups that i'm in also
florida's governor race is this year too
really i didn't know that florida's
governor races this year look that up so
when i saw that video uh the photos of
of aoc at that event with no mask on
people were cheering for her and like
dancing and i'm like who are these these
these florida democrats that like aoc
who supports mask mandates
and vaccine mandates
but are in a state where they don't have
that
won't abide by those rules which they
could choose to do if they want to i i
don't understand help me out what
nothing doesn't make sense no but nobody
knows that's a glitch in the matrix
people who who like
want that to be happening man yeah it is
this year it's november
all right uh pioneer smokehouses says i
was thinking a lot about what could
trigger civil war and i think moving
voting control to the federal government
could be bigger than pro-life issue
is that um was it hr one
oh i'm not sure
yeah i think they're probably referring
to voting the voting bill
yeah
do you know anything do you guys know
anything about that no no luke's just
very quiet yeah
well they're trying to figure out a way
to pass it because
they don't they can't get their
filibuster on it so
oh that's right they were talking about
the filibuster yeah nombot says did you
really just reference langolier's omfg i
knew i loved you guys
there you go
hunter's crack pipe says just say
hunter's crack pipe is hard to put down
you know there was an interesting point
brought up about the the picture of
hunter biden with sleeping with a crack
pipe in his mouth
that someone who was smoking crack would
never fall asleep while doing crack yeah
i think i think my friend justin told me
this yeah it's an upper like people who
smoke they're wired they're crazy like
weed so they think that the photo may
have been like someone screwing with
them or maybe it wasn't crack maybe it
was something else maybe like a downer
that he was also smart i don't know what
could have been smoking i don't know it
was a crack pipe dude sure
luke are you familiar with i'm not
you're making a reference
i'm not an expert in uh crackheads to be
honest with you um i could try to keep
my dealings as far as away from them as
possible
all right michael holder says bring nerd
roddick back or one of the geeks and
gamers crew to school luke on game of
thrones love you luke but not a disney
ending is a selter level bad take well
hey that's your opinion subject whatever
dude like that's fine i'm entitled to
have my perspective and you're entitled
to have yours um
okay
cat's claws we're just gonna get we're
just gonna i'm just gonna have to read
it he says i don't like ian he's the
main reason why i haven't subscribed to
timcast.com
here's ten dollars for a great week
without ian and that was really nice
thanks love having luke around uh around
though
uh i like ian i think ian's great i
think often ian asks us moral questions
that um kind of break the echo chamber
and that's kind of the issue i mean
it's difficult because obviously we
don't want a bad show if people are like
you know unimpressed by ian's
either not either a lack of conversation
or or bad questions then i would i would
agree like it's an issue but like there
were really good there's been really
great conversations that ian he's got
views that many of us don't have and
it's good to have a different voice i
mean ian is for the death penalty and
he's like some hippie guy and it's
interesting views yeah
but he's also asked us stuff that we
don't normally think about which i think
is a good thing he asked us you know we
oppose the mandates but would we oppose
mandates for like if there was if there
was an ebola going around yeah and i'm
like that's a good question it's like if
you really think about it was it called
hemorrhagic fever hemorrhagic fever
hemorrhagic fever where you like bleed
internally from the fever
like if people were just walking around
their eyes started bleeding and they
vomited blood and collapsed i might be a
little more like i'm not going outside
ever again get on my house you know
right i don't know
ian is no no i'm asking you about
hemorrhagic fever
i'm not an expert in hemorrhaging fever
i'm just let me ask you the question if
people were walking around and started
vomiting blood and bleeding from their
eyes would you be like for or against
mandates did they see um
what's it called that cnn
what's it uh what's his name uh reliable
sources yes did they just see brian
settler yeah
whatever his name is
i'm against government doing anything i
don't give a damn
what ha what's going on they're going to
make the situation worse they're going
to figure out a way how eye bleeding is
going to uh be monetized for them and
they would they would create a policy
against eye bleeding but they would make
people uh everyone leave more people
you know i think i'd still be against it
though i think you know we thought we we
we talked about it i think i'd still be
against it because it would
self-regulate
if people were genuinely witnessing this
stuff they would absolutely everyone
would self-isolate
yeah you'd need no need there'd be no
need for this like intense policy or
anything as soon as the government says
don't do this there's going to be a
bunch of people who are going to want to
do something like people need to have
personal responsibility act on their own
wills and understand that the government
is never going to come in and save you
this naive belief that the government's
going to help you or watch out for you
is absolutely idiotic it has almost
never happened in recorded human history
and the more you believe in the idea the
more of the fairy tale you put into that
give that power uh the more you let
yourself down and put yourself in danger
all right planet says bannon's show
plays the video on the out to commercial
all the time yeah i mentioned that oh
the glow one yeah the song i don't know
who this guy is
um other than there's been some stories
about him like he's he's i guess he's
like what he he funds right-wing groups
or something or like right-wing projects
yeah
chinese billionaire opposes the ccp
about him
hook him up
settle dench says it's good to see that
ian survived an encounter with the
langoliers and i'm excited to see him
back on the show
well you know he's he's he's just not
here he should he i think he's actually
in the building right now but you know
not yet no he's not no no he won't be
here until after the show i've been
telling people like don't fly right now
man yeah yeah dude because i've got
family that are flying and i was like
you're gonna get stuck yeah they're
canceling all of these flights yeah i
got i i think it's really obvious
it's the holidays yeah they tell
everybody you've got to get a negative
test if you want to do x y or z many
people are like i want to make sure i
get tests before i see grandma so they
all do then all of a sudden you get mass
reporting of covid of surging through
the roof across the board and then all
of a sudden all the politicians are like
oh geez oh no lock everything down and
then these these people who are working
in the airlines they're all like oh wow
i'm sick i guess i can't come into work
so everything's just being shut down so
one of the things that someone was
pointing out i forget where i heard this
but i guess if you say that you have a
positive cova test you don't have to
come into work they can't do anything
about it you can just kind of call off
consequence free and i was like that's
kind of dangerous to incentivize that
kind of nonsense it's really going to
skew your numbers
all right um well i think i asked for
this but we got a ton of super chats
about the langoliers maybe i should just
do that at the beginning of every show
make a movie reference because then
people super chat and it's and it's good
for the show
i love it all right i gotta watch this
now marc dello russo says what are your
opinions on rfk junior's controversial
new book i appreciate his work but
skeptical because the truth is often
elusive what do you think luke um
absolutely great take you should always
be skeptical of everyone and just
because someone's on your side or
someone has the same beliefs as you
doesn't mean that they're always going
to be correct and honest and upfront uh
i personally like uh
rfk jr i think he does incredible work i
think he was also instrumental in
bringing up a lot of the round up uh
important court legal cases that are
happening right now so for me he's done
a lot of good work and i always try to
judge uh a person by the fruits of their
labors and there's a lot of fruit a lot
of positivity and a lot of good things
that were brought on by this man so he
has a lot of credibility
about the assertions made about the real
anthony faunchi i think it's there's a
reason why it's
one of the number one books on amazon i
think it's very thought-provoking and
it's providing people a perspective of
dr fauci that is the complete opposite
of what the media has portrayed him as
but if you want to be completely
intellectually honest you look at both
perspectives you make up your own
decision after hearing them out and then
look at what evidence suggests to be the
truth and that should be the side that
you should be on no matter what all
right mcchillis says winning the fight
against mandates is our last chance at a
non-violent resolution to get our
freedoms back we've got to start winning
local battles i went in to pick up a
to-go order and was turned away because
i refused to wear a mask that's crazy
you know you know i was thinking we've
got some plans for culture jamming
um i don't want to say too much about
what a lot a lot of our ideas are but
i'm ready to just go full on
i don't even want to say
civil disobedience because i think we're
going to work well within the system
like a good example would be buying a
billboard
yeah buying a billboard not to make a
public statement where it's like hey we
think mandates are bad but like
to call out
individuals and politicians to call out
uh let me just put it this way in unique
ways
that would be very culture jamming and
i'll give you an example um the yes men
you guys you guys know the yes men yeah
they did this very famous uh
stunt where they cloned a dow chemical
website and then i think it was the bbc
emailed the fake website saying we want
to get someone to come on and speak
about the beau paul disaster where
there's like a major chemical spill in
india i think it was in india and then
the activists goes on tv pretending to
be from this major chemical company and
then says we hereby take full
responsibility for the disaster we will
be liquidating union carbide to pay for
all of the damages and everyone and it
was like this huge moment and then dao
was like no no we do not accept and it
was like that's serious culture well
they said they would they would be
compensating the victims in this
particular case which made the stock go
down dramatically and have the company
issue a public
uh announcement saying no no no no no
the victims here are not going to be
compensated which put them in a very
difficult
space
and i remember that that moment it was
it was very sensitive it was very very
big and and yeah showed you what impact
you can make so i'm thinking about that
kind of stuff you know and i had some
ideas like
what would happen if you went to a
business that was like enforcing
mandates and just hired someone to hold
a sign in front of the business business
that said sorry we're closed
like make no reference at all to the
business make no reference at all to any
mandates or any political statements you
just hire a guy like stand right here
hold up a sign saying sorry we're closed
that's that's it i said nothing else
like is that
they would all of a sudden be like hey
how come no one's coming to our
establishment anymore so there's things
like that now i want to avoid actually
going after the little guy in any way so
that's why we're looking at you know
billboards and silly pranks and things
like this that are all
like not even civil disobedience just
you know pranks is probably a better way
to put it
like you know like weigh your mask take
this procedure because it worked so well
the first time you know something like
that i think would be pretty we got some
plans i don't want to reveal them but if
i sat on people would probably start
laughing back i get it i get it but if i
if i give you an example so maybe maybe
this will be up on like thursday or
something on the vlog so go to the go to
the cast castle vlog on youtube
all right chris from michigan says i'm
waiting for the apology from dave for
degrading himself by posing with patton
oswalt so
so disappointing he needs to do better
yeah yeah there's a compelling case to
make there yep i love this one tyler
says did you notice there's no movie
showings after one six but only in blue
states i saw it on decoy voice but what
are your thoughts more lockdowns
all right
i love this conspiracy theory what so i
saw this online and they were like
anyone notice that after january 6th
movie theaters are only showing one
movie and it's called the 355 which is
like i don't know some rom-com or
something oh yeah and then someone
responded with i think this means the
feds are going to start you know locking
down the country or they're going to be
an interstate travel ban and i'm like
you got all that because movies haven't
been announced yet i'll tell you what i
think is happening i think it's a new
year
and i think many of these websites
haven't been updated with show listings
that's it
although i gotta admit it i've i've
never noticed this before it could just
be that people finally notice something
happens all the time
every year on the first of the year they
have theaters haven't sent in their
updated lists
and that could be normal finally someone
noticed it and everyone thinks it's a
conspiracy
or sure i guess the government's going
to be locking everything down i suppose
but i really doubt it
all right ricardo says
greetings from brazil this week it's
going to be voted if children 5 to 11
need to be vaxxed in brazil also today a
three times pfizer jabbed journalist had
a sudden cardiac arrest live duck
ducking whoa really
yeah man wow well i can't say much about
that because
you need to look at larger uh data sets
to understand if it's if that if that
matters we've talked about the soccer
players sort of you know passing out and
collapsing
dr malone said something interesting joe
rowan's podcast and we're going to get
into this in the members only segment
because youtube is ban heavy and that's
kind of the problem but one thing i
think is interesting is that people need
to understand when you see stories like
this it's possible covid long covered is
is having this effect now
with that in mind check out the members
on the segment because we're gonna get
into greater detail about what this
means and how
you know how it pertains to vaccines
unfortunately let's be i gotta be real
with you
if you
youtube is is absolutely insane as it
pertains to uh censorship but we do have
some plans we've been thinking about how
to to push back
um with as as crazy as youtube is
getting
especially in an election year and so
one of the things we're planning on
doing is a sunday special a special
sunday episode i don't call it sunday
special it's a bench pre closet but a
special weekend episode and we're trying
to figure out how we can do that within
our current you know time frame and work
schedule so that way on itunes spotify
other podcast platforms we will have
like very serious publicly available
free
conversations that go beyond youtube's
stupid rules we do this on the website
with our articles but we also have the
members only segment which is you know
you got to pay for because we need to
support the infrastructure i also just
tell you it is really expensive to host
those videos it is really really
expensive if we could if we could host
it all and give it away for free we
would youtube when we do these shows
it's free for us we don't pay youtube to
host this content but that means we also
have youtube's rules so the strategy
then is okay we'll host our own videos
but it's really expensive and so we need
to basically be like here's how much it
costs to get access to the stuff one
solution is to put up a special episode
every weekend on other platforms like
it'll probably be on rumble it'll
probably be exclusive on rumble and then
also an itunes spotify so we're trying
to figure it out we'll see if we can get
to it i don't think i have uh you know
all the solutions worked out just yet
but
there's also a video going around
alleging showing citizens beating up a
local mayor who mandated vaccine
passports to eat and mandatory
vaccinations for children and that video
is going around allegedly showing that
mayor getting his
buttocks
carefully um
hit
there's a there's a feud i guess between
marjory taylor green and dan crenshaw
did you see this no i did not raymond g
stanley says mgt
is it mtg or or crenshaw
i don't know man
i don't know isn't crenshaw like a
liberal now like didn't he like
like his like that's what i've been
seeing all over social media
he supported red flag laws didn't he he
denied that though
neocon i think so yeah i don't know he
he had this video he had this podcast
clip where he was like he said something
about americans who rag on endless war
being like ill-informed or something i
think it was taken a little bit out of
context but i think it wasn't out of
context enough for me to defend the guy
i think you know he's been fairly uh war
hawkish yeah so people are calling him
the new john mccain or whatever he still
would be interesting to have on the show
and to have a real discussion with open
invite yeah
horace dunn says tim you absolutely
nailed the skeletor voice when did i do
the skeletal voice it wasn't in this
episode oh previously i don't know yeah
yeah i don't know probably
i don't i wouldn't be able to do it
unless i had like a way to do it i will
say though my friends i am um
my uh my lifelong dream it's been
accomplished i can retire happily now i
have an imdb as a voice actor i am the
voice of dr anthony fauci yes for four
freedom tunes and you know i was
thinking about i'm like sheamus got a
big channel i mean he gets half a
million views like yeah like think about
this how many people can say they're a
voice actor on a cartoon show that
regularly hits a half a million viewers
yeah wow yeah and and here's the thing
i'm not just the voice of fouchy on one
episode i'm on like seven
and then i'm also sjw's friend and i
voice myself yeah so uh uh childhood
dream of doing voice acting there it is
i'm in a cartoon show nailed it uh
sheamus hit me up like a couple weeks
ago the new fouchy one where he comes
down the chimney and he was like bro i
did a huge favor like can you read this
script oh my gosh and it was at like you
know noon or whatever and i was like
sure
and it was it's the one where fauci
comes down and kidnaps people because
there's too many people at a family
gathering
but without sheamus directing it's
really hard to do because i don't know
exactly what his vision is so i had
without him there i tried to read it
like
like 10 different ways over several
minutes so we could try and figure out
which you know inflection and which you
know speed made sense i ultimate i
thought it was very very hilarious
though but
anyway yeah um maybe maybe i will maybe
sheamus
will uh finally realize that i can do a
ton of voices and i don't just have to
be anthony fauci yes although i have a
lot of fun voicing anthony fetch how did
how did i end up doing that role no i
think sheamus was here and then i
started doing the fountain voice and
then he was like can you record
something yeah i guess
all right here we go brandon h says
guo wengue predicted j predicted jack
ma's disappearance check out august 2019
interview with kyle bass on real vision
finance luke we are change will love it
what's the video again i'm going to look
it up august 2019 interview with kyle
bass on real vision finance
guo wengue
all right
raymond g stanley jr once again he says
tim guys i'm worried if trump wins the
left will go completely nuts if it's any
other candidate they'll go a little
crazy what do y'all think i think if
trump runs and wins they'll literally
try to secede from the union good we
already saw that that sentiment coming
around coming out i mentioned all the
time the boston globe i mean
and antifa is going to be like now's our
chance
that'll be fun
all right no more input everyone
everyone completely agrees with me 100
100 uh a percent agrees
waffle sense i says the best scene ever
of don't look up is when the bill gates
character gets called a businessman i
was losing it oh is that was that a
reference to something
i don't know i don't know if there was a
reference but he was clearly one of the
big tech giants and a lot of people say
he was bill gates because of his voice
and because of the sweaters and i
absolutely agree i think it was steve
jobs the turtle neck was very steep that
was the presentation too
he was an amalgamation of those people
yeah
paul wallace says ian is a good guy
while he is a little off and he
sometimes gets stuck on semantic
arguments he does bring a unique
perspective much love you and crew when
we did the special event we had like we
would have like 100 something people at
the bar oh yeah and then i mentioned i
was like ian often brings up you know
he gets involved in semantic arguments
which i hate and everyone started
cheering and clapping like
that's the problem it's not a real
argument to be like i think this word
means that word and it's like dude let's
have a conversation about ideas not the
meanings of words yikes william ward
says crack is not an upper rolled with
people that did it they basically become
drooling zombies is that true i know
people who did crack they became hopped
up but like they were like whoa so i
have a source that says if you do enough
of these stimulants eventually you'll
crash out which makes sense because your
body can only do so much well crackheads
are like mystical figures they have you
know god-like powers as well
and also the ability to to like pass out
everywhere so yeah
pretty impressive
okay let's see what we got here
um i just had the youtube jump happening
oh that's the worst that's a jump yeah
so when super chats load all at once it
just
throws everything up
but uh appreciate all the superheroes
guys
things you may not hate says hi from
warsaw love you luke especially in the
little heart emoji i sent you guys a
pitch forrest trump stole the
oh okay um well luke uh do you have a
message in polish to all of our
politicians
just gotta
that's one way to get around the youtube
censorship
thrown out different languages make them
make them work for it for the censorship
something something interesting when uh
when um when i was in egypt
the egyptians thought the british guys i
was with were german it was really weird
and so they told me like if you speak
with a british accent they'll just think
you're speaking with a german accent i
guess and then they won't think you're
american but they can tell you're
american
based on the american accent it's really
weird so they were like just use an
accent when you speak to us and they
won't notice
that was the craziest thing yeah it
seemed to have worked i guess that's
really weird i just talked like this
croikey mate hey
and then like no one had any idea they
were like i don't know where that guy is
no i didn't really do that i was just
like i don't know what you guys are
talking about
cornelius butt knuckle says i've seen
many a crackhead that have been up for
many a day and they do get to a point
that if they've been up for so long
their bodies start to force them to
sleep yeah i legit seen one guy fall
asleep with the pipe in his mouth you
know what that makes a lot of sense you
pass out maybe maybe he was up for like
three days yeah and finally just like
what happens to someone to make him go
like that you know like hunter biden to
he's like a wealthy family you know what
i mean it's the wealth that does it
yeah
i gotta say you know i know a lot of
people in the suburbs of chicago and
they were like from wella families bored
and they just do drugs all the time yeah
yeah i mean the uh
the rulers of like the uae in saudi
arabia like they're always partying like
they're very they're all like hunter
biden but like way more successful like
you know
i think a lot of these people they like
like chase those kind of pleasures and
yeah decadence
all right we got one more here we got
one more this is uh
tack says you fired ian no ian i pee and
ian's flight was delayed he has returned
um thankfully safely and so um he's not
in the building yet though not quite yet
yeah about an hour about an hour yeah
that's crazy you're supposed to be here
super early in the morning yeah i know i
know oh okay but he landed right yeah
wow that's not i thought they said he
was going to get here at nine we should
have ian cam yeah
where is where in the world is he and
tracker it'd be funny if like when when
when ian doesn't realize people are
watching him he's like a totally
different person
he's like a stodgy staunch conservative
suit wearing with his hair tied back and
no glasses
and he's got an accent yeah all right
everybody go over to timcast.com become
a member we're gonna have a members only
segment talking about some very serious
issues um sometimes uh often and i think
this will broach uh
it's it's it's what's called spicy i'll
leave it there i won't go go to
timguez.com member segment will be up
around 11 or so pm smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share this
stream right now grab that url share
wherever you can if you really do like
the show it really does help it will
help us compete with the likes of all
these big mainstream media companies we
have no marketing none whatsoever i
thought about this maybe it's a mistake
we do have a marketing guy for like
posting stuff on social media and he was
like did you do any marketing and i was
like never it's like it's all organic
and i'm like yeah i guess it's like wow
and i'm like okay maybe we should do ads
because like other big channels have
done ads we've never done that maybe we
should do something like that but at the
mean for in the meantime you guys can
just share it if you like it yeah and if
you do then i suppose we deserve the
views so uh also follow the show tim
cast irl on like every platform you can
follow us on instagram where we post
clips from the show you can follow me on
instagram at tim cast where i just post
memes and other garbage and just i don't
know i just post trash whatever uh zed
you want to shout anything out
yeah i mean we're still um my friend
shot miss robia and i were still writing
at inquiremore.com on sub stack and i'm
contributing to a range of different you
know outlets in addition to that uh i
try to put this stuff out on my twitter
as well just my first name and last name
so what is it it's a
z-a-i-d-j-i-l-a-n-i that's my my twitter
so sweet set thanks for coming on i
released a pretty interesting video on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
about the shifting tides i just released
another master class on luconcensor.com
and another video on robert malone
specifically talking about the indiana
life insurance ceo and his comments
about the 40
excess debts in
a certain age groups so if you want to
see that video look uncensored dot com
hope to see some of you guys there
thanks for having me thank you guys for
tuning in for this first show of the new
year it's gonna be a doozy of a year i'm
feeling very positive i'm just really
intrigued to see what happens thank you
guys for joining us as we start this new
journey you guys may follow me on
twitter where i post a bunch of nonsense
just like tim uh 24 7 pretty much at
sourpatch at sarah patch let's see i
forgot my handle there you go
timothy
yeah yeah we'll see you guys over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you